bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le site du
Figaro bienvenue sur la page Youtube du
Figaro on est en direct et on est avec
vous pour ce meeting de Valérie pcrè
grosse pression sur la candidate LR elle
va parler seul dans 1 he qu maintenant
juste derrière moi ici dans le Zénit la
salle est quasi pleine vous voyez il y a
encore des militants qui sont en train
d'arriver alors on va être avec militant
on va être également on l'espère avec
quelques élus qui sont ici aujourd'hui
réunis on a vu un certain nombre on
voyait tout à l'heure Patrick stéphanini
le directeur de la campagne de Valérie
pcrè à l'extérieur accueillir les les
nombreuses personnalités qui sont ici
les nombreux élus on va faire le point
avec Emmanuel gallero du service
politique du figero qui couvre la
campagne de Valérie pcrè et également
avec lur Salvin directrice générale de
Cantard public et sur surtout surtout
avec vous vous commentez vous réagissez
vous nous posez vos questions et c'est
dans le studio du Figaro Albane B qui va
recevoir vos questions qui va les
centraliser et c'est à elle qu'on donne
maintenant la parole bonjour en effet je
suis dans les studios du Figaro et je
vous donnerai la parole dans le chat du
Figaro sur la homepage du Figaro et sur
la page d'accueil de YouTube j'attends
vos commentaires et vos questions que je
relirai pendant ces heures de
meeting
merci beaucoup Albane on est donc avec
Emmanuel gallero du service politique du
du Figaro Emmanuel comment comment est
l'ambiance à l'intérieur en tous les cas
qu'est-ce qui vous frappe à l'intérieur
actuellement et comment s'est préparé ce
meeting alors c'est une ambiance de
meeting donc déjà ça commence à sonner
très fort Valé P a compris qu'il fallait
qu'elle booste ses équipes parce que
elle a eu des points de fragilité dans
cette campagne dans ce début de campagne
elle n'a pas encore cranté le public les
gens la regardent parfois la découvrent
mais nont pas encore compris
complètement son projet ni exactement sa
vision de la France et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'elle va faire aujourd'hui elle va
essayer d'exposer ce projet là et
d'essayer de convaincre tous ces gens
qui viennent la salle fait environ 6800
personnes on va probablement dépasser
les 7000 le but c'est ça c'est de
cranter enfin cette campagne qui a tardé
à à démarrer alors on va je vous promets
on va aller tout de suite on va aller
pas tout de suite mais on va aller dans
cette salle mais pour l'instant il y a
énormément de monde il y a énormément de
bruit à l'intérieur peut-être que
Emmanuel va nous dire pourquoi parce
qu'il y a une animation qui est qui est
faite avec une d qui est une habitué
paraît-il des meeting de Valérie PCR
semble-t-il Valé P la connaitt bien
puisqu'elle l'utilise dans dans ses
meetings c'est une DJ techno et c'est
c'est le le la modernité de sa campagne
elle veut imprimer en fait quelque chose
elle joue la carte face à Macron elle
veut imprimer une modernité face à
Macron et elle veut dire moi je suis
l'avenir Macron c'est le passé donc on
est on est un peu sur ce mode là de de
de compétition alors on va aller donc
c'est l'ambiance est assez techno en
fait à l'intérieur donc ça ça tape fort
leurelvvin qui est arrivé un peu avant
les équipes du Figaro c'est pour ça
qu'on est un petit peu en retard parce
que c'était pour tout dire un petit peu
un petit peu chaotique l'arrivée et donc
on a mis un petit peu de temps à à se
mettre en place mais l'or qui était en
en vigie a pu s'en apercevoir donc elle
a les oreilles un petit peu Bour donné
par toute cette musique bonjour lur pour
vous quel est le quel est l'enjeu de ce
meeting qu'est-ce que doit absolument
réussir Valérie pcrè tout à l'heure
alors effectivement il y a beaucoup de
bruit à
l'intérieur
et nous revenons dans quelques instants
au zénites de Paris où nous semble-t-il
nos équipes ont un tout petit souci
technique en attendant je vous appelle
chers internautes à commenter le direct
dans le chat du Figaro sur la page du
Figaro lefigaro.fr et sur la page
Youtube du Figaro Figaro live en direct
sur la la la page du meeting pour le
meeting de Valérie pcrè où vous pouvez
commenter en direct et poser toutes vos
questions que je rélerai à Vincent et
Laure Emmanuel galero qui sont sur place
et qui pourront y répondre tout au long
de ce meeting en
attendant j'attends vos commentaires et
toutes vos questions dans le
chat on a une première question de de
Charles Martel qui nous dit bonjour à
toutes et à tous Charles Marcel bonjour
internaute fidèle du Figaro que je
salue j'espère que pekras sera au second
tour elle a plein de parrainage c'est
une question que nous pourrons poser où
en est-elle des parenages
euh et nous la poserons sans sans sans
hésiter à à lors Salvin qui pourra sans
doute y répondre est-elle bloquée nous
attendons de voir en attendant je vous
le rappelle nous avons un petit souci
technique que nous essayons de régler
tout de suite dans nos studios en
attendant de retrouver la connexion
euh nous attendons de voir si nous
allons pouvoir retrouver les images
bientôt il semble que ça
revienne en attendant je vous invite à
commenter
encore le meeting et à poser toutes vos
questions car nous pourrons les relayer
tout à
l'heure et les poser àors Salvin notre
politologue qui est sur
place et nous
retrouverons nous reviendrons dans un
instant en attend en essayant de régler
ce souci
technique
il semble que nous avons retrouvé la
connexion avec le zénite de Paris
Vincent je vous laisse tout de suite la
parole effectivement on a retrouvé la la
connexion ben il y a beaucoup de monde
il y a beaucoup de caméras la salle du
zénite qui est juste derrière moi est
une salle qui est assez sphérique certes
mais assez petite en fait et donc très
avec une forte densité ce qui explique
que on peut avoir des problèmes de flux
comme on vient d'en avoir et on vous
présente bien entendu toutes nos excuses
vous restez avec nous vous continuez à
commenter à réagir Alban a donné tout à
l'heure les quelques premières réactions
que vous nous avez donné et
just justement pour y faire écho et je
reviens vers lur Salvin
puisque la rupture de flux lui a couplé
le sifflé tout à l'heure donc l on
reprend quel est l'enjeu actuellement
pour Valérie PCR à travers ce meeting
alors il y a un enjeu de remobilisation
en tout cas de mobilisation de ces
troupes ça c'est clair après cette
semaine passée qui a été compliqué euh
pour elle lui donner une assise un petit
peu plus forte aussi euh euh et puis euh
affirmer cette légitimité qu'elle a eu
dans les urnes puisque finalement c'est
quand même la candidate qui a été
désignée c'est la seule euh qui a été
désignée par euh par les militants je
pense aussi qu'il y a un enjeu auprès
des euh des Français qui ne savent pas
encore pour qui ils vont voter ils sont
39 % ces Français ils ne savent pas pour
qui ils vont voter donc voilà quelle
partie elle va pouvoir grignoter je
dirais et enfin je pense aussi qu'il y a
un enjeu pour elle parce que bah
finalement la campagne est dure et et
difficile et c'est aussi un moment pour
elle de de de s'inspirer et de se
nourrir de la ferveur populaire pour
continuer ces quelques semaines encore
de campagne alors Emmanuel vous êtes
arrivé tout à l'heure comme l d'ailleurs
bien avant
nous sur cette question de la ferveur
populaire est-ce que en tout cas les
milit temp répond présent en ce moment
derrière nous à aux élites de Paris
aujourd'hui oui on les entend ils sont
d'ailleurs très nombreux ils vont
probablement dépasser le le nombre de
personnes qui étaient
attendu c'est vrai Queau début de la
campagne on a suivi depuis le début dans
les meetings les gens venaient plutôt
pour la découvrir il faut savoir que V
PC c'est présidente de la région
île-de-fance qu'elle a une notoriété en
île-defance mais qu'elle souffrait d'un
manque de notoriété à l'échelle
nationale cette campagne est assez
courte et l'un de ces défis aussi pour
elle c'est de se faire connaître donc il
y a les meetings massifs comme ça mais
il y aussi les émissions de télé où elle
a les gens la découvrent et et
commencent à se dire pourquoi pas tiens
c'est une femme d'où elle vient
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait et ça aussi il
faut qu'elle le présente c'est pour ça
aussi qu'elle a un déficit de notoriété
et et d'image son problème d'image c'est
que les gens l' perçoivent souvent comme
quelqu'un d'assez dur d'assez rigide qui
qui ne correspond pas vraiment à la
réalité et c'est ça qu'elle veut
corriger elle veut essayer de le faire
comment va se dérouler euh le meeting
qui où elle doit prendre la parole
maintenant dans un petit peu moins d'une
heure alors ce meeting il est vraiment
centré sur elle c'est moi ma vision pour
la France la Nouvelle France c'est son
slogan d'aujourd'hui la Nouvelle-France
elle va essayer de le décliner et donc
dans la salle il y a aussi beaucoup
d'élus des gens de la société civile et
ils vont faire certains vont intervenir
par des questions par des des réponsesl
vont être questionnés par des par des
gens de la société civile pour donner un
peu de corps à à cette salle mais c'est
elle vraiment la vedette c'est elle
qu'on va écouter et on va voir si son
message prend ou pas quels sont les
thématiques sur lesquelles elle a
intérêt à
elle a intérêt à dont elle a intérêt à
parler sur lesquel elle a intérêt à se
positionner pour justement imprimer
puisque paraît-il d'après ce qu'on peut
lire notamment dans Le Figaro c'est son
principal problème aujourd'hui alors la
priorité aujourd'hui des Français he
dans la campagne c'est le pouvoir
d'achat donc effectivement on l'attend
sur cette thématique là on l'attend
également sur la thématique de la
sécurité de l'imig
où Marine Le Pen et Eric Zemour sont un
peu en avance par rapport à elle et puis
il y a une thématique sur laquelle les
candidats ne sont pas beaucoup à l'heure
actuelle et y compris le potentiel futur
candidat Emmanuel Macron c'est
l'éducation l'éducation ça fait partie
quand même des priorités des cinq
priorités des Français aujourd'hui
éducation et puis dernier point c'est
l'emploi également le pouvoir d'achat le
niveau des salaires le niveau des
retraites aussi sont des thématiques
attendues mais il y a également l'emploi
et le dynamisme économique notamment du
pays est-ce que ce sont des thématiques
sur lequel elle va revenir tout à
l'heure dans son discours Emmanuel oui
dans ce discours là elle va redécliner
tout ce qu'elle a dit dans les
territoires c'est qu'on va revoir une un
un tableau de toute sa de tout son
projet et alors c'était les critiqu
qu'on lui faisait elle était très
technique mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que elle a conçu sa campagne aussi
comme candidate de de de la réussite et
surtout d'un projet ficelé c'est-à-dire
elle dit toujours moi mon projet il est
financé et je suis la seul à avoir un
projet ficelé et c'est pour ça qu'il est
très technique son projet elle a décliné
et à chaque fois elle a dit ce qu'elle
allait faire du coup les gens évidemment
n'accrochent pas forcément et c'est sa
difficulté elle a dit je veux bâtir per
par per mon projet là je vais l'exposer
donc elle est toujours dans cette
difficulté c'estàd on sait qu'une
présidentielle il faut entraîner les
gens et on nentraîne pas les gens avec
des mesures techniques et ça c'est son
défaut de d'élu technicienne he elle a
été ministre elle connaî ses sujets par
cœur mais elle veut être très très
précise pour aussi pour aussi pour un
enjeu de crédibilité parce qu'il s'agit
de reconstruire un pays et c'est la
carte qu'elle veut jouer face à ses
principaux concurrents notamment Éric
Zemour et Marine Le Pen en disant
écoutez moi j'ai eu des exécutifs à
diriger eux jamais donc elle va aussi
jouer là-dessus merci Emmanuel pour ces
pour ces premières précisions Albane je
vous donne la parole le temps que je
vois encore des militants qui sont en
train d'arriver ça vous les voyez pas
parce que ça se passe juste derrière la
caméra de de
le temps que on essae de trouver
justement un ou une de ces militantes
qui viennent en ce moment et qui qui
vont rentrer dans le dans le dans le
meeting dans pardon dans la salle de
meeting et on va leur demander pourquoi
ils sont là qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent
de ce meeting je vous laisse la parole
vent j'ai une première question de jeun
viève men duumont qui nous dit la
question dépasse la personne de Valérie
PCR elle-même qui peut encore faire
confiance au
républicains
votre votre prénom pardon Monsieur
Didier Didier alors nous rons en direct
Alban vous me reposez votre question
parce que j'étais en train de parler
avec Didier qui est militant et je vois
je vois également d'autres d'autres
respons
oui Vincent je vous laisse interviewer
cette ce militant qui va répondre à vos
questions tout de suite
euh d'accord alors bonjour Didier
bonjour Pourquoi d'où venez-vous d'abord
cemar pourquoi vous êtes venu
aujourd'hui au meeting de Valérie pecr
parce que ça fait 60 ans que je fais
partie de cette famille j'ai jamais
changé les noms ont changé c'est tout
mais les vrais n'ont pas changé
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce
meeting ben j'attends qu'elle qu'elle
montre plus d'ardeur vous trouvez
qu'elle montre pas assez d'ardeurant
qu'elle elle est très bonne sur les
problèmes techniques elle connaît mais
elle a besoin de renverser un peu la
table vous comprenez j'ai bon tout le
monde ne peut pas être Sarkozi ou Chirac
qui avait des talents pour pour
enthousiasmer les foules mais elle elle
doit elle doit elle doit qu'est-ce que
vous sur quel thème vous
l'attendez bah surtout ce qui surtout ce
que n'a pas fait Macron surtout ce qui
bah c'est que bah de toute façon alors
quand j'end j'entends que Monsieur vert
je vais pas parler beaucoup de lui vous
comprenez j'end Monsieur B dit que la la
caisse n'est pas cramée elle est cramée
il suffit de comparer avec les pays
autour de nous voyez la dette la dette
est àissale elle parle de la dette elle
parle du problème de l'immigration il
faut en parler il faut en parler et puis
parler des problèmes qui nous touchent
tous aujourd'hui c'est bien de parler
mais qu'est-ce qui a été fait la
sécurité monsieur darmana qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait et pourtant c'est un de
chez nous mais toute façon tous ceux qui
sont comme ça qui veulent partir faut
surtout qu'il partent estce la
concurrence ceux qui sont partis donc je
comprends bien chez Emmanuel Macron ça
ça vous ça vous atteint pas est-ce que
ceux qui sont partis chez rour ça vous
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire sont
partis chez chez Macron ça me dérange
pas du tout parce que chez Macron vous
savez c'est un grand une grande marmite
il y a beaucoup de socialistes je vois
qu'il y a même monsieur Bartelone qui a
envie de venir chez Monsieur bon
pourquoi pas qu'il aillent tous c'est
pas c'est pas ma TASS qu'est-ce que
j'attends vous disz ceux qui sont partis
chez c'est autre chose toute façon euh
il a Éric Zemour par rapport à
à à Valérie pcrè bon c'est le le le le
c'est ce que faisait Jean-Marie Le Pen
il y a il y a 30 ans vous voyez bon il
il a dit des choses vrai d'accord qui a
qui ont le mérite d'être ditite et qu'il
faut mettre sur la table c'est tout mais
enfin de là à devenir président de la
République non non non non merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté de répondre aux
questions du Figaro et puis je vous
laisse va aller suivre ce meeting qui va
démarrer pour ce qui pour Valérie pcres
d'ici d'ici un peu plus d'une heure je
vous en prie mais de toute façon je suis
infidèleeur du Figaro c'est très bien il
faut continuer et si vous êes
Jean-Félix Vincent juste c'est important
de dire que aujourd'hui dans ce meeting
il y a les jeunes de Valéri PES qui sont
mobilisés il y a environ 2000 jeunes sur
l'ensemble ce qui fait quand même un
pourcentage assez important et
Jean-Félix est là peut-être qu'il peut
terer sur les raisons de sa
venironjoursur bonjour bienvenue donc
sur le en direct sur le sur le site du
Figaro sur la page Youtube du figarou je
suis et vous fait vous faites bien il
faut continuer exactement comme le le
font le font comme le font également en
ce moment les les internautes qui
réagissent et qui nous posent des
questions peut-être que on en aura
peut-être à vous poser euh pourquoi vous
êtes là aujourd'hui ben pour soutenir
une candidate une famille politique à
laquelle j'appartiens depuis des années
et à laquelle je suis resté fidèle c'est
vrai que on assiste à des défections
depuis quelques qu jours des rumeurs ici
et là ça vous atteint ça vous affecte
c'est le lot des campagnes électorales
mais si vous voulez c'est toujours
l'aspect très politicien j'avais un
souvenir du président de la République
actuelle qui parlait du Nouveau Monde et
je dois dire que depuis tout ce ququen
ça a été jalonné par des ficiel de
l'ancien monde donc c'est ça qui est
assez intriguant ça fait toujours mal
surtout que Éric vert avait une position
de d'homme sérieux compétent sur les
questions économiques et le fait qu'il
fasse desffctions à ce moment oui
forcément c'est toujours au moins ça met
ça met de la clarté qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de ce
meeting redynamiser la campagne euh
alors je ne sais pas si elle patine com
on dit je non non mais je sais pas si je
tomberai dans le vocabulaire qui
consiste à dire que effectivement il
faut redonner un souffle mais je crois
que j'entends souvent l'expression chez
vos confrères sur les plateaux qui
parent de fond de l'armure alors reste à
savoir ce qu'on y met vous pensez que
que valéie PCR qui vient non que Valérie
PCR pardonnez-moi de ce lapsus c'est
l'actualité maisf ça c'est un autre vous
pensez que Valérie pcrè qui a redit ce
matin dans les colonnes de nos confrères
du JDD que elle était une femme pudique
peut fendre l'armure ce qui compte c'est
vous saz l'élection présidentielle j'ai
toujours pensé et on l'enseigne
d'ailleurs dans l'Emmanuel d'histoire
politique c'est la rencontre d'un homme
d'une femme et d'un peuple donc je crois
qu'à un moment les Français ont besoin
de savoir qui est le candidat il s'agit
pas d'aller savoir t les les les les
recoins de la vie privée mais il faut
voilà il faut se donner au peuple voilà
il faut se donner il faut vraiment se
montrer moi j'ai un souvenir quand
j'avais commencé la politique quand on
s'engageait en 2007 la campagne Nicolas
Sarkozi on parlait lui matin midi soir
voyez il se donnait il y avait une
énergie il y avait une ardeur on le
connaissait il y avait un caractère un
tempérament et je crois que c'est ce
qu'elle doit faire elle est très
compétente en plateau dans des débats
parce que elle est très pointue sur des
questions économiques elle est brillante
intellectuellement à titre personnel
mais maintenant il faut avoir cette
capacité à entraîner vous voyez ce que
je veux dire se donner entraîner
susciter un engouement susciter un élan
un parler si vous voulez quelque chose
voilà c'est un peu ça c'est ce que on
attend ce meeting je crois que ce sera
fait la campagne est encore longue et
voilà il faut avoir l'ESP il y a du
monde qui continue d'arriver là
actuellement et est-ce que
justement ça vous ça vous donne du
courage pour continuer cette campagne
disais don l'espoir ça permet d'espérer
de croire la campagne n'est pas
terminéein selon les Institutes de
sondage les 2e et les 3e voilà on verra
je veux dire il faut se battre jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au mois d'avril et on y croit
par qu'elle est quand même je regardé un
dernier sondage 70 % des gens pensaient
que voilà c'était celle qui était le
plus à même à à battre Emmanuel Macron
donc je crois que voilà il y a quand
même il y a les chances merci beaucoup
Jean Félix d'avoir voulu d'avoir accepté
de de témoigner et on va vous laisser
justement continuer de suivre ce meting
une petite précision parce qu'on voit
des gens rentrer encore en ce moment
alors qu'ils devraitê déjà dans la salle
et on a eu un témoignage à l'instant de
deux personnes encartées qui ont été
refoulé faute de place et ils étaient un
peu un peu énervés mais ça montre que
les gens sont venus en masse aujourd'hui
et que ils vont pas pouvoir accepter
tout le monde il y a aucun dispositif
qui est prévu à l'extérieur comme par
exemple pour les meetings deori non
alors est-ce qu'ils vont l'improviser ou
faire quelque chose pour éviter que ces
gens repartent déçus je ne sais pas mais
en plus le temps est pas pas terrible je
ne sais pas je on les encourage en tous
les cas à suivre le meeting s'ils
peuvent pas sur le site du Figaro avec
vos commentaires également les
commentaires de l'URE avant de prendre
justement et de répondre à certains de
vos questions et à certains de vos
commentaires chers internautes peut-être
on fait le point euh l'or puisqu'on
parlait des sondages où en est
actuellement Valérie pecrè dans les
sondages et dans vos indicateur chez
quantard alors dans les sondages elle
est assez stable à l'heure actuelle
quand on regarde d'ailleurs la plupart
des sondages elle est au coude à coude
avec avec Eric
Zemour et devancer de quelques de
quelques points encore par par Marine Le
Pen mais c'est vrai qu'on a ces trois
candidats alors pour le moment donc
Emmanuel Macron même s'il n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat serait le
premier en tête de des sondages mais
ensuite nous avons donc ces trois
candidats euh Marine Le Pen Valérie pcrè
et Éric Zemmour qui joue un peu voilà
pour savoir qui va être le le le le le
second et celui qui accédera au au
second tour euh vous disiez justement
que elles sont ils sont très proches en
tous les cas en terme de de score et de
de score crédité avec Eric Zemour euh
est-ce qu'il y a un risque pour elle de
croisement de courbe c'est-à-dire que éc
Zemour passe devant elle alors à l'heure
actuelle c'est pas encore mais oui bien
sûr il y a il y a il y a un risque
effectivement et les derniers jours les
dernières semaines de la campagne vont
être décisifes qui va justement arriver
à à mobiliser autourhui alors l'avantage
de Valérie PCR c'est que elle a un
électorat euh très stable un quart
d'électorat très stable espérons que ça
lui prend chance on va voir ça Xavier
Bertrand est en train de prendre la
parole à l'heure où justement vous nous
donniez ses explications Xavier Bertrand
ça a été l'un des concurrent Valérie PC
l'un des favoris au départ pour cette
primaire on lui laisse la parole on y
revient juste
après chacun a sa chance chacun a sa
possibilité chacun peut
réussir et chacun peut
réussir pas
seulement pas seulement ceux qui vont
très bien pas seulement ceux qui vont
moins bien mais ceux qui sont au milieu
ceux qui sont les éternels oubliés avec
Valérie PC ce quinena sera le quinena
des classes moyennes oublié depuis des
années et qui porte la France qui
symbolise la France et qui font la
France mais ne nous racontons pas
d'histoire vous connaissez Valérie sa
marque de fabrique son ADN ce sont les
résultats sa marque de fabrique c'est le
courage le courage de dire la vérité si
nous voulons réussir si nous voulons
créer des richesses alors il faut du
travail il faut qu'il y ait plus de
personnes qui travaillent il faut que
l'on accepte de travailler un peu plus
longtemps et surtout il faut travailler
plus pour gagner plus oui ce projet
Nicolas sarcosi est toujours d'actualité
parce qu'il a été oublié depuis 10 an et
c'est ce que Valérie veut porter à
nouveau
alors alors il y a ceux qui donnent du
travail qu'il faut aider ce ne sont pas
les politiques qui créent du travail ce
sont les entrepreneurs qui créent du
travail les entrepreneurs des très
grandes entreprises des petites et
moyennes entreprises mais aussi des
artisans des commerçants des professions
libérales et ce qu'ils veulent eux c'est
qu'on leur fasse confiance ce qu'ils
veulent eux c'est que l'État lâche prise
ce qu'ils veulent eux c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas la culture l'obsession du
contrôle mais aussi tout simplement de
l'accompagnement c'est au cœur du projet
de Valérie PC voilà ce que nous voulons
mettre en
place mais il faut
aussi il faut aussi que le travail paye
à nouveau et que la différence soit
claire qu'elle soit net qu'elle soit
franche entre celui qui travaille et
celui qui pense qu'on peut s'en sortir
sans travailler oui nous devons réformer
l'assurance chômage la France ne peut
pas rester ce pays dans lequel vous
pouvez dire non à 2 3 4 5 10 offres
d'emploi et il ne se passe rien si nous
voulons revenir vers le travail il
faudra tendre la main mais celui qui ne
voudra pas tendre cette main alors les
règles changeront et les indemnisation
baisseront voilà ce que nous devons
faire
oh en disant cela j'ai conscience que ça
ne plaira pas à certains mais c'est le
prix de la vérité et c'est effectivement
le courage qui nous impose de le dire et
puis il y a celles et ceux qui ne
travailleront pas ou qui ne
travailleront plus et c'est ce que
disait iigénie notre droite n'est pas
une droite dure avec les plus fragile
c'est la question des retraités ah les
retraités situé dans le colis de
Monsieur Macron dès le début de son
quinquena je ne sais pas quel est son
problème avec les retraités mais il ne
les a jamais respecté jamais parce que
leur carrière ils ne l'ont pas fait à 35
he avec des conditions de travail qui
n'étaient pas les mêmes pour eux il n'y
a pas d'Ur supplémentaire pour eux il
n'y a pas de 13è mois il n'y a pas de
prime de Noël mais ils ont le droit au
respect du pouvoir d'achat et pour que
ce pouvoir d'achat soit respecté alors
il faudra avoir le courage de mener la
réforme des retraites qui s'impose c'est
ce que propose Valérie et c'est ce que
nous
le courage et la justice et c'est notre
famille politique qui aé cela beaucoup
ici s'en souviennent jacquesacait voulu
François Fillon avait porté cette
réforme de courage c'est nous qui avions
permis à ceux qui avai commencé à
travailler très jeune très dur de partir
à la retraite plusôt oui c'est vrai dans
l'ADN de la droite il y a le courage et
il y a la justice nousons de soevoir de
personne et aussi
ceux qui ne pourront pas travailler les
personnes
handicapées et là nous nous inscrivons
dans quel filiation celle de notre
famille et
jackirac les grandes réformes en matière
de retraite ne cherchez pas c'est la
droite et le centre mais les grandes
réformes en matière de handicap c'est
jacquesirac JAAC Premier ministre JAAC
également président de la République 746
2005 une lo V c'est bien loqu c'est
mieux voir un troisème rendez-vous de
solidarité avec la justice pour les
personnes handicapées et c'est ce que
Valérie veut faire en mettant en place
notamment cette mesure quand le dernier
des parents disparaîtra l'enfant
handicapé devenu adulte bénéficiera de
la pension de reversion en plus de
laallocation d'adultes handicapés ce
témoignage que j'avais reçu pendant la
campagne montre une chose rien ne peut
remplacer l'angoisse des parents qui se
disent comment ça se passera après notre
départ mais la solidarité elle doit être
au rendez-vous parce que nous nous
faisons la différence entre l'assistana
qu'il faut rejeter et la solidarité
qu'il faut promouvoir c'est cela notre
droite la Droite
populaire alors mes
amis je le dis la droite courageuse elle
est dans cette salle avec Valérie PCR
elle n'est nulle part
ailleurs la Droite populaire celle qui
parle à toutes et tous à ceux qui vont
bien à ceux qui vont moins bien mais
aussi aux classes moyennes qui portent
le pays elle est dans cette salle et
nulle part ailleurs elle est avec
Valérie
PC et vous savez que cette nouvelle
France elle sera synonyme de justice
elle sera synonyme de courage de travail
d'autorité mais aussi de territoire
voilà la France de Valérie voilà ce que
nous voulons une nouvelle France pour la
France pour les Français c'est avec
Valérie PCR que nous saurons relev ce
[Applaudissements]
défi
on veut vous entendre dans la salle sur
vos drapeau remercier Xav Bertrand et
continueer sur des on va gagner on va
gagner et on l' entendu le discours de
Xavier Bertrand qui doit précéder celui
d'Eric cotti tout à l'heure il a plaidé
pour une droite forte une droite
courageuse avant avant le discours de
Valérie PCR dont on le sait le souci
aujourd'hui est d'imprimer de de de
marquer le le paysage électoral entre
Emmanuel Macron et les récentes
défections qu'il y a eu au sein de du
parti politique LR euh notamment celle
d'ericv qui a été un gros coup porté à
la droite la droite des républicains euh
mais face à cela voilà Xavier Bertrand
l'a dit la droite est forte la droite
est courageuse et on entend
d'ailleurs et on entend d'ailleurs
d'autres prises de Paro qui se succèdent
on va peut-être retrouver Vincent rou
notre journaliste sur place qui est avec
lur Salvin politologue pour répondre à
toutes vos questions que j'attends dans
le chat du Figaro Vincent vous avez la
[Musique]
parole merci Alban effectivement alors
on vient d'entendre donc Xavier Bertrand
qu'est-ce que d'abord ça vous inspire
euh est-ce que c'est pas aussi le signe
que il y a une remobilisation même dans
l'entourage de la campagne parce que on
avait moins vu Xavier Bertrand ces
quelques jours ces derniers jours tout à
fait je pense que c'était très
symbolique effectivement qu'il soit là
qu'il prennent la parole dans les
premiers on l'a vu il il l'appelle
Valérie d'ailleurs je pense que un des
enjeux d'aujourd'hui c'est donner de la
chair justement à cette candidature de
personnaliser aussi cette candidature et
puis ils viennent d'annoncer que le
Zénit est complet et que ils ont ouvert
une are salle juste à côté pour
accueillir toutes les personnes que nous
voyons tout à l'heure et qui étaient un
peu désemparé de ne pas pouvoir rentrer
ici donc effectivement il y a quand même
beaucoup de soutien aujourd'hui Exavier
Bertrand en fait partie et je pense que
symboliquement c'est important pour la
candidate un peu désemparé et un peu
énervé même d'ailleurs parce que
certains viennent de loin faut voir faut
savoir qu'il y a une à l'extérieur il y
a une vingtaine de cars avec à
l'intérieur des des militants qui ont
été
amené ici au meeting de la plus grande
tradition des meetings finalement du RPR
de
l'UMP le est Renou avec la tradition des
mobilisations militantes pour les
meetings absolument et je sais pas on en
SAA un petit peu plus dans les dans les
prochaines heures je ne sais pas encore
ce qu'on va ce qu'on va dire mais ce qui
se disait ici et là c'était justement
qu'ils avaient pas eu besoin de beaucoup
mobilisé dans les régions qu' avaient
pas affritter tant de car que ça que
finalement les militants c'étaient aussi
beaucoup mobilisés eux-mêmes par leurs
propres moyens et finalement voilà qui
se retrouvaient ici sans y avoir été
particulièrement encouragé quoi que ce
soit peut-être le signe d'une
mobilisation individuelle plus forte on
verront dans les prochaines heures alors
moi ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
essae de voir maintenant on va essayer
d'avancer avec DAP peut-être que le flux
va couper parce qu'il y a énormément de
monde on va essayer de voir justement
comment se déroule ce meeting en
o nous sommes
c'estd vous parler depuis énormément de
bruit là ça se ça se calme un
peu on va pouvoir
regarder la S
il semble qu'on a un petit souci
technique avec la connexion aux zit de
Paris en attendant nous voyons sur les
images les derniers soutiens de Valérie
PCR qui ont pris la parole on a aperçu
Christelle Morancé Gérard Larcier
Christian Jacob actuellement on voit la
prise de parole de agès Evren qui est
une qui est une des porte-paroles de
Valérie PCR on a également Hervé Morin
qui prend la parole donc que des des
grandes figures de la droite de la
droite des républicains on a aperçu
d'ailleurs sur les images tout à l'heure
vous l'avez peut-être vu il y avait
gerérard R qui était présent un des
internautes a reconnu également Rachid
adti voilà ce succète d'autres reprises
de parole on a Yan Verling actuellement
vous le voyez sur les
images qui soutiennent
voilà en prenant la parole Florence
portellier également maire de
taverern qui
apporte leur soutien par des messages
vidéos diffusés dans le meeting leur en
voquier président de la région auverne
ronalpe qui soutient également Valérie
PCR qui est un un poids lourd dans la
dans la
campagne de Valérie PCR et un soutien
précieux pour elle on s'en
douteo je sais que
sercellente présidente vous le voyez
ensuite le soutien de Michel
tabaroobis derè et nous reprenons pour
moi c'est une femme de cœur une femme de
fidélité une femme d'engagement et si
derrière elle aujourd'hui je suis
présent dans cette campagne c'est parce
que les sujets en matière d'énergie en
matière de climat en matière de
préservation de la planète sont
importants pour elle je soutiens Valérie
PCR car est la candidate de l'audace la
candidate du courage et la candidate de
la jeunesse je sais que Valérie PCR
saura redonner de l'espoir à toute notre
génération et à tous les Français alors
engagez-vous le 10 et 24 avril vote pour
Valérie PCR tendre la main avec
fraternité envers ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin c'est Valérie pcrè qui nous
guidera demain sur ce chemin de
redressement d'une France plus juste et
plus belle parce qu'elle défend nos
convictions et que son projet est fort
pour la France nous soutenons Valéri PCR
mes chers amis la France que nous aimons
c'est ce combat toujours recommencé
contre le fatalisme contre le déclinisme
la France que nous aimons c'est la
France que veut rebâtir que veut
reconstruire Valérie PCR alors de toutes
nos forces avec Valérie nous disons nous
aimons la France et nous voulons la
faire gagner ma chère Valérie nous te
demandons non seulement de nous apporter
le succès mais en plus par la pratique
que tu auras de nous rendre la
démocratie c'est tout ce que nous te
demandons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons te soutenir je
soutiens aussi Valérie parce que c'est
une femme politique qui a du cœur et qui
donnera toute son énergie toutes ses
compétences pour redresser son pays je
soutiens Valérie PCR parce que elle
incarne cette France de l'égalité des
chances que nous appelons tous de nos
vux je soutiens Valérie PCR parce
qu'elle est la seule à pouvoir nous
débarrasser d'Emmanuel Macron ce que
nous voulons Valérie c'est une femme qui
n'est pas dans un mode de gouvernance
domination c'est une femme qui va
susciter l'adhésion une femme qui saura
alli ambition pragmatisme proximité je
soutiens Val PC parce qu'elle a un
projet puissant pour le redressement du
pays basé sur l'autorité sur la liberté
et la dignité et parce que c'est la
seule capable de battre Emmanuel Macron
c'est une bonne personne c'est quelqu'un
de bien je la connais depuis près de 20
ans
elle est intègre elle est déterminée et
elle a surtout cette qualité qui à mes
yeux fondamentale elle aime les gens et
je suis fier d'être à ses côtés parce
que c'est une femme qui a du courage
merci Valérie pour le travail que tu
fais pour le rassemblement que tu as
réussi et pour la victoire que tu vas
nous apporter dans quelques jours une
femme à la présidence de la République
et ben ça ça REM monontrerait sacrément
au reste du
[Musique]
monde
vous l'aurez compris mes chers amis la
droite le centre est réuni autour de
Valérie pcrè les images parlent
d'elle-même je me trouve actuellement
dans le carré des jeunes qui sont les
forces vives de cette
campagne plus précisément au côté de
Quentin vous les avez entendu se sont
succédés différents messages de soutien
des porte-paroles de Valérie P des
grandes de la droite notamment et
maintenant Vincent je vous laisse
reprendre la parole avec lur Salvin en
direct du zénite de
Paris alors vous vous le voyez pas
pardon vous ne le voyez pas ma chère
Albane mais là où je me trouve alors on
est un petit peu à côté du carré VIP du
carré press du carré VIP et on voit
Patrick Stéphani le directeur de la
campagne de Valérie PC des élus
également d'île-defance qui essayent de
de rentrer et de voir où euh visiblement
en tous les cas c'est ce qu'on se dit
euh où ça en est avec une discussion
avec les les responsables de la sécurité
Laur Salvin nous disait tout à l'heure
que il y a une deuxième salle qui a dû
être ouverte et effectivement il y avait
quelques protestations de de militant on
a entendu pendant qu'on se parlait tout
à l'heure sur les des protestations de
militants qui n'arrivaient pas euh à à
rentrer on a essayé de de vous montrer
quelle était l'ambiance un peu en
immersion puis là effectivement comme il
y a beaucoup de beaucoup de monde et et
que euh la la la 4G pour tout vous dire
sature un petit peu les images se sont
figées mais on a pu avoir un aperçu de
l'ambiance qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
alors justement euh l'ambiance qu' qu'on
a pu euh qu'on a pu un petit peu toucher
que qu'on a pu un peu sentir on sent une
ambiance très jeune déjà alors
effectivement c'est le propre des
meetings de mobiliser
aussi un électorat qui est comment un
peu plus fragile un peu moins sûr
d'aller voter aussi les jeunes
aujourd'hui notamment ceux de 18 24 ans
bah finalement ce monde parmi les plus
hésitants de de la population ce qu'on a
pu voir aussi sur les écrans c'était
différents élus
politiques qui donnit leur soutien à
Valérie pcrè et ça je pense que c'est
important aussi de montrer qu'elle est
soutenue qu'elle est entourée oui Hervé
Morin qui a été très applaudi Jean
rotner également le président de la
région Grand Est tout à fait Florence
Sportelli enfin pas mal de effectivement
de d'élus de terrain qui compte et je
crois aussi que c'est une des
différences de de la candidate par
rapport aussi aux autres candidats
Valérie pcrè c'est justement cet ancrage
territorial alors ancrage dans les en î
de France pour elle mais c'est quelque
chose qui est très présent dans ses
discours l'ancrage dans les territoires
de France et et au sein de la population
alors euh je sais pas si euh justement
Albane on l'a encore vu euh pour
l'instant mais euh si euh vous avez
navez pas vu en en haut du Figaro ce
matin euh doit intervenir tout à l'heure
ou a dû intervenir euh l'un des
personnages qui a été au centre d'une
grande polémique ces derniers jours euh
suite à la diffusion par nos confrères
de M6 d'un documentaire sur l'islamisme
à roubé le juriste qui est intervenu qui
a été d'ailleurs l'objet de de
nombreuses menaces par la suite doit
intervenir en ce moment justement aux
zénites avec dans un dialogue avec Eric
sotti lor euh on entendait tout à
l'heure la la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui était qui était soulevé en
tous les cas la question de la dette qui
était soulevée par un des militants euh
la question de la sécurité en tous les
cas et la question de de l'Immigration
et de l'islam sont des thèmes quand même
quand on entend parler les les militants
qui qui reviennent quand même souvent
dans les conversations h oui tout à fait
je crois que le pouvoir d'achat reste
quand même une thématique importante et
et primordiale notamment pour les
catégories
employés ouvriers et puis les jeunes
aussi c'est une question que qu'il se
pose autre sujet qui qui est un peu dans
dans dans les esprits on l'a entendu ici
ou là aussi c'est les petites retraites
les petites retraites des voilà des des
Français qui sont aujourd'hui retraités
qui ont du mal
à bah finalement à à joindre les les
debouts et puis il y a aussi un sujet
dont on ne parle pas trop ici c'est
l'environnement alors même que les
Français souhaitent que dans tous les
programmes et dans toutes les visions
qu'on peut avoir maintenant aujourd'hui
aussi de la France il y ait une
dimension environnementale en tout cas
de transition écolog logique pour amener
la France dans un futur plus agréable
aussi à
vivre sétait positionné quand même sur
ces sujets là semble-t-il plutôt mais au
moment de la campagne pour les
régionales tout à fait effectivement et
là maintenant on attend on attend d'elle
un positionnement un petit peu plus
global une vision aussi de la France
dans cette transition écologique dans le
monde également merci Laur Salvin pour
ses réponses et pour ses éclairages
Michel Barnier est en train de prendre
la parole autre concurrent de Valérie
pcrè pour la campagne on va l'écouter on
y revient juste après cher
Alban redevienne une vraie puissance
influente il y a beaucoup d'atouts et
beaucoup de leviers à condition de bien
les utiliser de savoir les utiliser
j'observe par exemple que on aurait pu
mieux utiliser depuis 5 ans cette
formidable force que constittuent nos
départements et régions d'outremer
présent dans les trois
océans je pense qu'on aurait dû mieux
utiliser cette formidable force
qu' je pense qu'on
aurait duû mieux utiliser cette
formidable force qui est le casadre de
la Francophonie 500 millions d'hommes et
de femmes parlent français bientôt 1
milliard dans le monde je pense qu'on
aurait dû mieux s'appuyer sur les 3
millions demi de Français qui vivent et
travaillent à l'étranger et qui portent
une partie de la l'influence
française tu sais Quentin
euh le vrai baromètre la vraie
photographie du déclassement de la
France c'est notre commerce extérieur
qui s'est effondré 87 milliards de
déficit alors même que l'Allemagne est
en excédent depuis longtemps et que même
l'Italie devient en excédent pourquoi
sommes-nous en déficit parce que nous
nous avons sacrifié notre capacité de
production industrielle et agricole et
puis notre pays c'est aussi quelque
chose que je vous dis à regret et de
moins en moins populaire il y a de plus
en plus
d'antirance notamment en Afrique alors
même qu'il y a tant à faire avec cet
immense continent voilà je pense aussi
enfin que pour devenir fort pour
redevenir fort pour devenir influent
pour être capable de donner des leçons
aux autres il faut commencer par faire
le ménage chez soi on ne peut pas être
fort à
l'étranger on ne peut pas être fort à
l'étranger si on a un tel déficit et un
tel endettement c'est-à-dire une telle
faiblesse chez nous en France voilà
chers amis je suis heureux d'être parmi
vous pour plusieurs raisons pas
seulement pour tenir la promesse la
promesse de loyauté d'unité que nous
vous avions faite le soir de la
primaire avec Éric cioti avec Xavier
Bertrand a philippe Juvin avec Valé PRCR
nous avons pris cet engagement d'être
ensemble derrière celui ou celle qui
aurait gagné le plus de vos suffrages et
nous faisons simplement aujourd'hui ce
qui est notre honneur ce que nous vous
avions dit ce J
mais l'autre
raison c'est que je sais c'est que je
sais que Valérie pcrè est à la hauteur
est à la hauteur de la responsabilité
que nous voulons pour elle et pour la
France je l'ai vu j'étais avec Bruno
rotillon qui est ici quelque
part l'autre jour en
Arménie défendre avec une telle clarté
la liberté religieuse notamment pour les
chrétiens
d'Orient nous
étions je l'ai
vu oui oui oui attend laissez-moi juste
terminer je l'ai vu en Grèce avec Eric
sootti avec Nadine Moran et quelques
autres élus euh parler clairement avec
le Premier ministre grec monsieur
Mitsotakis notre ami un premier minist
de droite courageux qui fait ce que nous
devons faire partout sur nos frontières
extérieures pour qu'elle ne soit plus de
véritables passeoir comme elles le sont
depuis trop longtemps donc je je sais
que Valerie pecr à ses qualités et je
sais qu'elle avec elle la France sera
fiers nous serons fiers en étant moins
arrogant je sais que nous serons plus
forts en étant moins solitaire je sais
que nous resterons
européens sans être
naïf voilà pourquoi chers amis chers
Quentin j'ai toutes les raisons de vous
inviter à faire campagne jour après jour
tous les jours qui passent d'ici le 10
avril pour porter Valérie pécr à la
présidence de la République parce que je
sais qu'avec elle la France sera
respectée
vous pouvez applaudir Monsieur Michel
Barnier un grand serviteur de l'État
patriote et européen vous pouvez
vraiment
l'applaudir alors après ces quelques
témoignages de grands élus et
aujourd'hui on a quasiment plus de 1000
élus locaux que je vous demande
d'applaudir et des parlementaires vous
pouvez les applaudir parce qu'ils ont
fait le déplacement c'est aussi ça la
droite et le centre assemblée nous
allons maintenant regarder une vidéo de
personnes issu de la société civile
parce que pour gagner il faut rassembler
alors on vous montre une petite vidéo
avec des témoignages très importants
pour Valérie
PCR dans les pas de Jac Chirac en corz
je mène un combat un combat qui est
important pour moi c'est celui de donner
aux personnes handicapées des conditions
de vie les plus proches de tout un
chacun de tout citoyen et au-delà des
discours convenus des postures il y en a
certains qui ont une fibre qui ont une
approche une considération Valérie pécrè
que je côtoie maintenant depuis presque
15 ans elle a toutes ses aptitudes
elle a ce qu'on appelle le Chirak Spirit
la compétence l'écoute la considération
la persévérance et par-dessus tout ça
l'humanisme en tant qu'homme de culture
je soutiens Val P moi je la connais
Valérie elle vient au théâtre elle va au
concert elle est proche de nous elle
nous écoute elle nous entend je sais
qu'en tant que président de la
République elle sera une femme de
culture une femme qui aime la culture
une femme qui donne accès à la culture
Valérie on a besoin de toi la culture a
besoin de toi parce qu'on a eu jusqu'à
présent un président qui était peut-être
cultivé mais qui n'était pas un homme de
culture tu seras une grande présidente
une grande femme de culture je soutiens
Valérie PCR parce que c'est une femme
qui a en ligne de mire cet horizon de
bien commun pour la France je m'appelle
lisraou et je suis militante associative
cela fait bientôt 10 ans que je me bats
pour la création d'un droit à l'oubli
par les malades de cancer le droit à
l'oubli c'est la possibilité pour les
malades d'emprunter de l'argent sans
payer de surprime assurancielle pour moi
l'exercice politique c'est la poursuite
du bien commun alors il s'agit pas de
faire des effets de manche ou de grands
discours il s'agit d'agir et de faire
pour moi Valérie pécrè c'est une femme
qui fait les choses je m'appelle
Jean-Marc mmec ex-champion du monde de
boxe anglaise je soutiens Valérie car je
reconnais ses qualités sa détermination
ainsi que sa volonté à vouloir être dans
une société où tout le monde trouve sa
place c'est pour ça que je soutiens
Valérie PC je suis Céline Yar je suis
agricultrice en production de grandes
cultures et multiplication de semences
dans le Tarne en région Occitanie je
soutiens Valérie pcrè à plusieurs titres
d'abord en tant que femme et en tant que
personne parce que je pense que les
valeurs qu'elle porte sont des valeurs
essentielles aujourd'hui à la au
redressement de la France au
redressement du pays je la soutiens
aussi parce que en tant qu'agricultrice
je pense aujourd'hui l'agriculture est
un secteur stratégique qui est trop
souvent oublié et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui de par son programme de
par les valeurs qu'elle porte elle sera
redonnée de la fierté de la confiance au
monde agricole et ça pour moi c'est un
indice extrêmement fort de sa capacité à
gouverner on a besoin de retrouver une
cohésion de décentraliser massivement ce
qui est pas égalien de revaloriser la
valeur travail c'est ce que Valérie va
nous apporter c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis à ses côté c'est ça
Valérie c'est une femme qui aime les
autres c'est c'est une femme qui est
fidèle en l' amitié elle est sincère
elle n'hésite devant rien quand elle
décide de faire quelque chose elle va
jusqu'au bout elle est fidèle elle
Estelle a bon cœur elle est humaine et
c'est toutes ces qualités qu'il faut
avoir la on vient d'entendre Michel
Barnier qui est une des personnalités
importantes de cette de cette campagne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut retenir de ce que
de ce qu'il a déclaré et qu'est-ce qui
vous a
marqué alors déjà moi ce en terme de
scénographie pardon hein mais c'est vrai
que ici on est quand même aussi sur
l'image en terme de scénographie il est
il était en dessous de la scène juste
juste devant la scène mais pas sur la
scène donc on va voir si les autres
preneur de parole se mettent à la même
au même endroit c'est quand même
intéressant en terme de positionnement
c'est-à-dire que ils sont vraiment là
pour soutenir en tout cas moi l'image
que ça me donne c'est vraiment un
soutien à la candidate et et puis
Barnier insistait sur le fait
effectivement qu'il était important que
la la candidate soit soutenu ENF soutenu
dans le dans le long terme et y compris
dans les prochaines semaines et enfin
moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est aussi cette
idée que c'était avec avec Valérie pcres
que la France pourrait avancer et aller
plus loin notamment en terme de respect
des droits respect de la laïcité et euh
et et place dans le monde voilà et on
voit actuellement Florence Sportelli qui
est en train de d'arriver donc la mire
de teverny qui est également l'un des
l'un des soutiens de Valérie PCR Michel
Barnier bien sûr aussi c'est sont les
questions européennes puisqu'il a été
commissaire européen il a négocié la le
brexit et la sortie de la Grande
Bretagne de l'Union européenne est-ce
quelle est l'attente des électeurs
aujourd'hui sur la question européenne
et en particulier quelle est l'attente
des électeurs de
droite alors ce que les Français ont
particulièrement apprécié pendant cette
crise cette pandémie en fait c'est
justement que l'Europe soit soudée et
apporte des solutions pour améliorer la
vie
des des citoyens dans dans toute
l'Europe donc je pense que les attentes
c'est qu'effectivement la place de la
France soit renouvelée
soit plus forte dans cette Europe qui a
qui a montré quand même malgré tout que
en période de crise et bien elle était
là aussi pour pouvoir protéger les
citoyens Albane est-ce qu'il y a
actuellement des commentaires est-ce que
je je pense qu'il y a je ne pense pas je
suis sûr qu'il y a des commentaires il y
a des réactions il y a des questions
est-ce qu'il y a des questions que les
internautes se posent auxquelles nous
pouvons répondre et auxquelles lur
Salvin peut répondre
oui oui tout à fait Vincent les
commentaires se succèdent dans le chat
du Figaro et je vous invite internaut à
posez toutes vos questions en attendant
je vous en pose une Vincent on a je qui
nous demande la question dépasse la
personne de Valérie pcres elle-même qui
peut encore faire confiance aujourd'hui
aux républicains alors la la
problématique aujourd'hui est telle que
de la difficulté de Valérie PCR à
imprimer ou elle elle est la
problématique est davantage une question
de d'évolution du paysage
politique
je continuerai de prendre la parole face
à qui s'est
installé alors on va poser la question
alors justement une internaute dit que
le problème aujourd'hui dépasse la
personne même de Valé PCR qui peut faire
encore confiance au républicains est-ce
que c'est un défi d'ailleurs dans
l'opinion pour les républicain de
restaurer la confiance avec une partie
de l'opinion ou bien est-ce
que républain on un autre est-ce que on
a parlé justement du défi d'imprimer
mais est-ce que c'est pas le défi de la
confiance que les républicains doivent
donner et en particulier ce reproche qui
est fait d'être élu à droite par exemple
etre gouvern au centre alors la
confiance effectivement elle est clé
aujourd'hui pour la population française
pour les citoyens et notamment pour les
jeunes parce qu'effectivement ce qu'ils
peuvent
reprocher au personnel politique
aujourd'hui c'est justement ben cette
perte de de confiance donc il y a quand
même pas mal de points de vigilance à
avoir ici il faut pas surpromettre on a
vu anniealgo en début de en début de
campagne qui a annoncé des mesures les
Français n'y ont pas cru en fait ils ont
eu le sentiment qu'on se moquait d'eux
parce que ces mesures étaient jugées
extrêmement peu réaliste en fait et je
crois que la confiance elle se elle
s'incarne aussi quand on on prend appui
sur la réalité sur le terrain avec des
exemples très précis et très concrets de
ce qu'on veut faire merci beaucoup l je
pense qu'il y a une nouvelle prise de
parole qui va
être FA et donc on va écouter cette
prise de parole et on y revient juste
après on va aller l'écouter
peut-être combat sera long et je voulais
remercier Valérie PC Bruno r éti Michel
Barnier laurentier Xavier Bertrand pour
le soutien qu'ils nous ont apporté et
nous gagnerons ensemble vive la droite
républicaine vive la république et vive
la
[Applaudissements]
france merci amine pour ton courage et
ton combat parce que la République elle
est partout chez elle et pour te
répondre qui de mieux que celui qui nous
vient de Saint-Martin vubi un village un
village des Alpes Maritimes il a présidé
ce département il en est aujourd'hui
député il aime cette belle terre
nissoise et bien j'ai envie que vous
applaudissiez monsieur
[Applaudissements]
éricti merci chers
amis quelle joie quel
bonheur de vous voir
milit militant de nos familles
politiques militants de la droite
républicaine mais surtout militant de la
France cette France que nous aimons
cette France que nous voulons voir
grandir cette France que nous voulons
voir au sommet sur les sommets sur
lesquels le général de Gaul Georg
Pompidou Valérie gardestin jacesirac
Nicolas Sar
laav alors oui merci à amine merci à
amine albai ce jeune courageux qui a
porter le message le message d'une
France qui ne cède pas qui ne recule pas
qui ne baisse pas le regard face à la
pression du communautarisme islamiste il
est aujourd'hui menacé il est
aujourd'hui menacé comme le sont des
journalistes comme le sont des
enseignants qui ont eu le courage qui
ont osé dire la vérité dénoncer les
fléaux qui nous menacent et qui
aujourd'hui prennent à otage des
quartier oui il a dénoncé la montée de
cet islamisme qui conquière les âmes et
les territoires et bien aujourd'hui
c'est en pensant au courage d'Amine que
je veux dénoncer que je veux dénoncer la
lâcheté de ceux qui d'ors et déjà se
sont soumis que je veux dénoncer la
lâcheté d'un gouvernement qui durant ce
quinquena sous la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron comme ce fut le cas sous la
présidence de François Hollande à céder
à concéder du terrain aux ennemis de la
République alors oui aujourd'hui nous
attendons que le courage prenne enfin
les reennes de l'État par la présidence
de Valérie PCR
oui
[Applaudissements]
oui nous aurons besoin de ce courage de
ce courage pour dénoncer les petits
renoncements et surtout les grandes
lâchetés qui ont guidé les pas
aujourd'hui de ce président de la
République qui n'a pas voulu mener et
livrer ce combat vital pour la survie de
la France que nous aimons le général de
Gaul disait la France vient du fond des
âges elle vit l'avenir l'appelle pour
aant qu'elle sache rester elle-même oui
l'enjeu c'est que la France reste la
France l'enjeu c'est qu'aucune règle
religieuse ne soit jamais supérieure aux
lois de la République
[Applaudissements]
l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est que la France
héritière du siècle des Lumières
héritière du millénaire capétien c'est
que la France héritière d'une
civilisation
judéo-chrétienne comme héritière de la
Révolution française que la France
héritière de l'empire héritière des
hussards noirs de la République que la
France de clémenenceau que la France des
marins de l'île de sain qui regenèrent
le général de Gaulle à Londres que la
France des maquisars du plateau des
Glières mon cher Laurent que la France
de la 5e République derrière le général
de Gaulle celle du sursaut celle de la
grandeur et bien demain puisse encore
avoir un avenir c'est tout cela qui est
en cause c'est tout cela qui nous réunit
oui nous voulons que la culture
française rayonne toujours et non
monsieur Macron la culture française
nous vous le disons elle est là elle est
forte et elle existe oui nous
voulons que la
France que la France ne s'excuse pas d'ê
elle-même non monsieur Macron la France
n'a jamais commis de crime contre
l'humanité en Algérie ou ailleurs et
nous le disons en nos frères piedsnoirs
et arquis qui ont incarné cette fidélité
et cette fierté française oui nous
voulons que demain la France retrouve la
grandeur et pour cela elle a besoin
d'autorité elle a besoin de force elle a
besoin que la loi de la République
s'applique partout qu'il n'y ait plus
des zones ou des quartiers de non droit
qui seraiit livré selon la formule même
du Premier ministre de l'Intérieur de
Monsieur Macron Gérard Colomb aux
islamistes ou aux narcotrafiquants ce
n'est pas nous qui l'avons dit c'est un
ministre de Monsieur Macron alors
oui le temps du sur saut est venu le
temps de l'autorité
est venu nous en avons une ardante et
une impérative nécessité pour redresser
la France pour cela nous avons besoin de
l'autorité nous avons besoin du courage
d'une femme qui dans ses responsabilités
à la tête de la région Île-de-France a
témoigné en toutes circonstances de son
engagement pour la défense de de la
nation c'est elle c'est elle qui a eu le
courage de combattre contre le
communautarisme c'est elle qui a eu le
courage d'interdire le port du birkini
dans les piscines d'île-de-fance à
l'égal à
l'égal de ce qu'avait fait deux grands
présidents de la République courageux
Jacques Chirac avec la loi sur
l'interdiction du voile à l'école en
2004 merci françois Barouin qui a été
aussi l'inspirateur de cette grande loi
toi qui est ici aujourd'hui au côté de
Valérie c'est le courage de Nicolas
Sarkozi un très grand président de la
République auquel je dis ma
reconnaissance et ma fidélité qui avait
eu avec Valérie avec Laurent vquier avec
aussi le courage de dire qu'il fallait
interdire le port de la burka dans
l'espace public et bien
demain Valérie pécrè aura la même
autorité aura la même
force pour faire reculer tous ceux qui
se sont érigés un ennemi de
la publique oui nous avons besoin de ce
chemin oui nous avons
besoin de ce courage pour que la France
reste fidèle à ce qu'elle a toujours
été pour que la France puisse continuer
à éclairer le monde fort de son histoire
fort de ses racines fort de ses
grandeurs et pour que demain avec
Valérie pécre elle puisse retrouver le
chemin de de la grandeur vive la
république et vive la
[Applaudissements]
France ch
bravo bravo cher Eric ces sujets ne sont
pas les sujets portés par les les
extrêmes nous aussi la droite nous
défendons l'ordre la liberté la laïcité
et tous les autres sujets que certains
tentent de nous récupér à l'URE où on se
parle Valérie PCR est en train de se
préparer à rentrer et à monter sur la
scène puisqu'on vient de nous écarter
pour pouvoir laisser
passer la candidate sur les les allées
où se trouvait notamment la
presse éicti a incontestablement gagné
cet après-midi à l'applaudimettre avant
Valérie p visiblement effectivement il
avait de nombreux soutiens dans la salle
il a parlé beaucoup justement de l'islam
de la lutte contre l'Islam et de cette
nécessaire fermeté aussi que devait
incarner j'allais dire la présidente la
candidate des républicains dans cette
campagne voilà quand merci pour pour
cette cette cette analyse à Chud de de
la prise de parole d'
si vous êtes si vous dressez
l'oreille vous devez entendre que là la
l'ambiance est en train de de monter en
tous les cas tout est fait pour préparer
l'arrivée de Valérie PEC ici derrière
derrière nous peut-être Alban est-ce
qu'il y a un commentaire d'internaut
auquel on peut répondre en attendant la
prise de parole par la
candidate on va peut-être parler avant
on va peut-être lui donner la parole
Alban
président
AUO
[Musique]
présé pour envoyer toute votre énergie à
la salle du Cabaret Sauvage parce que
ils sont plus de 1000 dans cette salle
tellement la qui belle et je vais en
profiter pour saluer tous ceux qui sont
au premier
rang et je vais vous demander de leur
faire un tonner d'applaudissement parce
que ils sont le
visage de notre famille politique de la
droite et du centre rassemblé pour
gagner je vais vous demander de saluer
Yann Verling qui représente les
centristes et également les écologiste
un vrai centriste depu très
longemp le président des du groupe LR au
Sénat et maintenant Damien AB le
président du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale peut-être une allez rapidement
un commentaire Albane et après on vous
fait vivre
l'événement comaire d'un internaute qui
nous disait é qui réagiss à la prise de
parole d'é qui nous disait aura
rejoindreour au vu de son positionnement
sécuritaire
libéral poser la question à Salvin
est-ce que quelle différence y y a-t-il
vraiment entre le le sur la la la
sécurité entre ERC Zemour et Valérie
becc la prochaine personnalité vous la
connaissez c'est un modèle de
méritocratie ça a été une grande
ministre de la Justice aujourd'hui M une
opposition de qualité face à elle est
déterminée parce qu'elle est toujours
présente quand sa par politique a besoin
d'elle alors je de faire qu est la
différence
entreour
et sur la question de la sécurité
pendant que on signale peut-être
l'arrivée de rachidati qui est
longuement
appr alors la question de la sécurité
effectivement il y a plusieurs
thématiques qui sont
chèes au candidats au différents
candidats différentes
personnalitésti lui en tout cas dans le
discours qu'il vient de faire là à
l'instant il a beaucoup parlé
des banlieux des problématies de
sécurité donc sur les territoires de
l'islam également et des problématiques
d'identité une visionz identitaire alors
que peut-êtreour a une vision un pe plus
globale parle davantage lui du Grand
remplacement parle absolument pas c'est
peutêtre est différenci
principalement tous les
deux vient d'être ovationné un peu plus
longuement que les autres candidats
pendant que il était appelé justement
par la personne qui anime et qui chauffe
la salle depuis tout à l'heure avec un
certain talent je dois le dire et
d'autres personnalités sont sont appeler
peut-être un autre commentaire puisque
la candidate se fait encore attendre un
autre commentaire alman et on essaie d'y
répondre oui tout à fait encore un
commentaire Vincent sur la prise de
parole que nous venons d'entendre avant
de entendre la prise de parole de
Laurent Bouquier peut-être ouun d'un
autre élu LR un internaute réagissit en
disant quelle que soit sa compétence
n'est pas éicti qui veut c'est vrai que
Valéri était secondé à l'issu du des
résultats du Congrès
parti qu est-ce qu'elle aurait intérêt à
s'appuyer davantage sur sur les
questions portées parti à savoir la la
sécurité et les questions de de de
défense de
sécurité parce que vous allez passé un
moment unique ce momentique vous une se
fois il
a on parler alors merci à tous et c'est
[Musique]
parti est-ce que Valé a intérêt à à
s'appuyer encore plus sur les questions
porté et en tout cas à mettre encore
plus en
valeur revenir sur
sur les thématiques de sécurité
effectivement sur les thématiques de
c'est vrai qu'une grande partie de son
électoratatt sur ces sujets ça fait
partie de leur priorités les priorités
des électeurs de c'est qui à égalité le
pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
l'immigration donc effectivement ce sont
des thèmes sur lesqu on
l'attend fa pare des inquiétudes des
franaisère général et encore plus de
l'électorat de Valérie
PC Albane je sais pas si vous entendez
derrière moi mais la les militants les
plus de plus de 7000 militants qui sont
ici au Zénit parlent et Scand en boucle
on va gagner il y a encore un clip qui
est en train d'être diffusé on va
peut-être le laisser pour faire vivre
l'événement puisque maintenant l'heure
de la prise de parole par Valérie PC
s'approche on y revient juste après ça
doit durer environ 1 heure et on prendra
également vos commentaires on répondra à
vos questions et on débriefera avec l
Salvin à tout à
[Musique]
l'heure
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous attendons la prise de parole de
Valérie pcres qui ne va pas tarder en
attendant nous avons les images qui nous
parviennent des équipes de campagne de
Valérie pcrè mais la prise de parole de
Valérie pcrè est imminente nous
attendons bien sûr son discours qui ne
devrait plus
[Musique]
tarder
[Applaudissements]
mes chers
compatriotes de métropole des Outremers
et de
l'étranger
enfin enfin nous voici tous réunis
vous m'avez
[Applaudissements]
manqué merci merci à la magnifique
équipe de France qui m'accompagne bravo
à
[Applaudissements]
elle merci à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous de me donner votre
énergie vous êtes toujours là votre
affection me
c'est un privilège d'être votre candidat
de porter vos couleurs même si désormais
c'est au peuple de France que je dois me
donner
je suis en campagne du nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest je traverse le plus beau
pays du
[Applaudissements]
monde la France je l'aime corps et
bien plus je la parcours plus je l' trin
plus je l' trin plus elle m'émerveille
et plus je sens monter en moi une
impatience celle de voir notre nation
retrouver cette force qui appartient aux
nations
gagnantes cette force je l'ai en
[Applaudissements]
moins avec cette force je veux rallumer
avec vous les espoirs d'une nation
unique et
universelle une nation bâtie par des
femmes et des hommes qui par leur
travail leur bravoure leur génie
artistique et scientifique ont réussi à
Isser la France au premier
[Applaudissements]
rang contre les zigzags nous choisissons
les lignes droites nous choisissons
l'action qui libère les forces vives
nous choisissons l'audace de l'espérance
oui il y a toujours un risque à vouloir
être grand mais je vous l'assure tous
les chemins s'ouvrent à une France qui
se lève pour conquérir sa fierté et son
bonheur
oui c'est une conquête mais nous avons
un atout nous sommes français citoyens
d'un pays qui malgré ses doutes ses
lacunes reste splendide
[Applaudissements]
oui je le crois il y a un pacte 20 fois
séculaire entre la grandeur de la France
et la liberté du monde
[Applaudissements]
mais rien n'est acquis depuis 10 ans nos
gouvernements ont abîmé la France et
nous sommes à la croisée des
chemins pour la première fois pour la
première fois le sort du monde pourrait
s'écrire sans nous dans 10 ans
serons-nous encore la 7è puissance du
monde serons-nous encore une nation
souveraine ou un auxiliaire des
États-Unis un comptoir de la Chine
serons-nous une nation unie ou une
nation
éclatée face à ces questions vitales pas
de fatalité ni au grand déclassement ni
au grand
[Applaudissements]
remplacement je vous appelle au
sursut 5 ans c'était trop 10 ans ce sera
trop
[Applaudissements]
tard la pandémie de la covid a meurtri
des familles entières
elle a aussi jeté une lumière crue sur
nos fragilités nos vulnérabilités
cet état hyper centralisé incapable de
s'appuyer sur les acteurs locaux notre
système de soins bureaucratisé saturé
tenu à bout de bras par le courage
infini de nos personnel
[Applaudissements]
soignant
notre impuissance a développé un vaccin
en France pendant qu'un de nos brillants
entrepreneurs aux États-Unis cré
moderna notre système éducatif a la
peine avec des enseignants dévoués mais
désarmés par une révolution numérique de
retard notre addiction toxique à la
dépense et à la dette alors on nous dit
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais jusqu'à
quand cette pandémie a montré aussi une
autre France la France qui a du cran et
de la responsabilité la France au front
celle des travailleurs de première ligne
ce des premiers trains du matin celle
des entreprises qui s'adaptent qui se
relèvent qui relanc la chaîne de
production celle des collectivités local
qui font la chasse au masque cell des
familles qui avalent lesoc
mais qui s'organise et qui se
ressoude celle des associations qui se
démèent auprès des capossés du
confinement cette épreuve a réveillé nos
aspirations
profondes celle d'une vie plus libre
plus douce une vie plus proche des siens
plus proche de la
nature ses attentes ses désirs il faut y
répondre je je veux porter un nouvel
espoir celui d'une nouvelle France que
nous devons reconstruire
[Applaudissements]
ensemble
France car notre pays est éternel
nouvelle car notre histoire reste encore
à écrire Nouvelle France car c'est elle
qui se nourrit de ses racines et qui se
donne des ailes la France des
cathédrales et celle des satellites la
France de pegy et celle de Marie Cury la
France qui s'assume et qui se réinvente
la voilà ma
France
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle
France réconcilier
oui je veux un pacte de réconciliation
nationale un Pact qui apaise les colère
parce qu'on ne gouvernera plus les
Français à coup de menton parce qu'on
cherchera pour eux des solution parce
qu'on les écoutera parce qu'on les
respectera une nouvelle France délivrée
de ces chaînes qui entravent l'audace
des entrepreneurs et des créateurs des
bâtisseurs d'avenir une France qui
réinvente son rapport au travail qui lui
donne du sens qui le récompense à sa
juste valeur une France qui ne sépare
plus les premiers de cord des
travailleurs de première ligne tous unis
tous en tête la voilà ma
[Applaudissements]
France une France connectée qui
multiplie les chances de mieux
s'informer se cultiver de mieux
travailler
connecté mais pas isolé devant son écran
perdu dans le métaverse il y a chez les
Français une soif d'authenticité
d'humanité une soif de
proximité c'est la France qui renaist
dans ces villages ses bourgs ces villes
moyennes qui retrouve le goût de
fabriquer en France d'acheter français
de savourer français et oui n en
déplaise à certains
un pavé charolet arronsé d'un bon vin ça
c'est la France autour de la
[Applaudissements]
table c'est la France qui se réchauffe à
l'amitié et à la famille qui respire qui
retrouve le goût de vivre la joie de
vivre la chance de vivre la voilà ma
[Applaudissements]
France ce mode de vie cette identité de
la France cette cohésion de la nation
nous devons nous battre pour les
protéger la France est une
personne écrivait Jules Michelet si sa
voix disparaissait ce serait une voix
singulière manquante pour le monde un
imaginaire en moins une identité en
moins jamais je n'accepterai qu'on vide
la France de sa substance jamais je ne
tolérerai qu'on la dévitalise qu'on la
banalise je combat les mouvements wist
et au-delà tous ces mouvements qui
veulent nous
déconstruire le WIS c'est la guerre des
races la guerre des sexes la guerre des
autographes la guerre des mémoire c'est
le contraire de la
République molir l'identité française
c'est démolir la force
[Applaudissements]
française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accuse Emmanuel Macron d'avoir cédé à
la repentance en reprochant à la France
un crime contre l'humanité qu'elle n'a
jamais
commis je l'accuse d'avoir racialiser la
question des banlieux je l'accuse de
vouloir déconstruire notre
histoire je l'accuse d'avoir nié
l'existence de la culture
[Applaudissements]
França non monsieur Macron le génie
français ne commence pas à la
Révolution et oui je veux Molière au
Panthéon car il est pour moi le visage
de la France qui salue l'humanité d'un
grand
rire oui
Molère Molère c'est l'esprit français
oui monsieur Molère au Panthéon et avec
luianarel Scapin et
[Applaudissements]
SIM la culture est notre ciment
national comme le voulait André mer nous
irons au bout d'un rêve celui d'offrir à
chacun de nos enfants dès l'école le
pouvoir de s'émerveiller par les arts et
la
[Applaudissements]
création du viaduc de mot au
monts-michel du phare de cordoin aux
fortifications de Van je veux aussi que
les Français se reconnaissent dans leur
patrimoine ils dessinent la carte de
leurs affections les plus intimes comme
de nos inspirations les plus
hautes aimer la France l'aimer
viscéralement c'est aussi aimer sa
nature nos paysages sont uniqu
magnifiques
inspirant l'écologie s'est imposée à moi
il y a
longtemps pour une raison simple qui
aime son pays le protège il le transmet
comme on transmet un
trésor nous empruntons notre planète à
nos enfants et aujourd'hui nous leur
devons d'être à la hauteur de l'urgence
climatique et ce'est pas
[Applaudissements]
cas tout
l'enjeu tout l'enjeu mes
amis sera de décarbonner la France sans
tomber dans la
décroissance c'est possible l'écologie
est une valeur l'écologie n'est pas une
idéologie c'est une solution ça n'est
pas une
[Applaudissements]
punitionésident
président
Président
présidentésident mes amis je veux la
France souveraine qui ne soit soumise à
personne une puissance d'équilibre
alliée bien sûr aux États-Unis mais non
aligné une puissance écouté une
puissance
respectée la France qui dit non à la
guerre en irac la France qui fait
reculer les chars russes en Géorgie moi
je ne me risou pas avoir la France
humiliée en Australie au Mali ou en
[Applaudissements]
Russie
au rus il faut parler avec fermeté en
cas d'attaque il s'exposerait à des
représailles économiques drastiques aux
Ukrainiens il faut parler avec franchise
et leur dire que l'adhésion à l'OTAN
n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour nous devons mettre sur pied une
nouvelle organisation pour la sécurité
européenne de l'Atlantique à loural
l'Union européenne en matière de
sécurité doit prendre son destin en main
il est temps d'avoir une goliste à
[Applaudissements]
l'Élysée
je suis patriote et européenne mais je
refuse une Europe impuissante je refuse
une Europe fédérale qui diluerait notre
identité et déclencherait de nouveau
brexit je veux une Europe stratège qui
respecte les États et fasse entendre une
voix puissante dans le monde une Europe
qui ne soit pas aotage des g femes une
Europe qui défende sa
civilisation
Emmanuel Macron pratique une diplomatie
de la posture alors qu'il faut une
diplomatie
d'influence
d'influence pas
d'arrogance à ce jeu les grands gagnants
ont toujours été les Allemands et les
Britanniques
oui Angela Merkel Margaret tchur deux
femmes ont toujours protégé leur peuple
elles ont défendu leurs
[Applaudissements]
int moi aussi président de la République
je vous
[Applaudissements]
défendrai
la décroissance agricole prévue par la
Commission de Bruxelles est une erreur
fatale à l'heure du réchauffement
climatique et des famines sur le
continent
africain je soutiendrai nos
agriculteurs et je protégerai notre
industrie je veux une vraie taxe carbone
à nos frontières je dis bien une vraie
une taxe sur tous les produits qui ne
respectent pas nos normes
environnementales et je défendrai notre
énergie nucléaire sans laquelle il sera
impossible d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone en
20050 cette énergie nucléaire que nous
avons forcé Emmanuel Macron à
redécouvrir aujourd'hui après la faute
de la fermeture de
Fessenheim
[Applaudissements]
face à un monde si
menaçant je protégerai notre industrie
de défense et nos
armées à nos soldats
à leur
famille je veux dire toute ma
reconnaissance et notre
admiration chef des
armées je seraiis une femme de paix mais
je saurais être chef de guerre si les
circonstances
l'exige je donnerai à nos forces armées
le cap la fierté moyens qu'exigent leur
mission
exceptionnelle et je leur dis le combat
contre l'islamisme au C je le
poursuivrai la mission n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
terminée
dans notre souveraineté tout part du
peuple et tout revient alors je donnerai
la parole au peuple de
France trop souvent il se sent bayonnés
il se sent méprisés quand les Français
réclament la diminution de l'immigration
quand ils demandent le retour à l'ordre
quand il réclam une France une et
indivisible nous devons leur donner le
pouvoir de
décider
[Applaudissements]
décider librement souverainement
démocratiquement
oui la démocratie oui le peuple plutôt
que le chaos dès mon élection je
réhabiliterai le référendum référendum
sur l'immigration référendum sur la
sécurité et la
laïcité contrairement à Emmanuel Macron
à Notre-Dame des land les résultats de
ces référendum je les
[Applaudissements]
respecterai
dans notre Constitution le chef de
l'État a l'initiative du référendum
cette initiative je la partagerai avec
les Français je veux un référendum
d'initiative populaire car pour moi la
démocratie ne se tire pas au
sort
il n'y a pas de souveraineté sans
frontières nous devons les
restaurer la frontière c'est comme la
porte de la maison cette porte nous
choisissons de l'ouvrir ou de la fermer
c'est cela être maître chez
soi et si pour cela il faut bâtir des
barrières voire des murs comme le
souhaitent les États qui sont en
première ligne face au chantage
migratoire je les soutiendrai
je veux qu'ensemble nous retrouvions le
contrôle de cette immigration débordante
qui débouche sur la création de zones de
non-
France je veux des quotas des contrôles
le renvoie des clandestins et si un pays
refuse de reprendre ses clandestins avec
moi ce sera zéro
visa
[Applaudissements]
face à la nation qui se fitû en silence
je revendique de vouloir
l'assimilation parce que je veux faire
des Français de cœur et pas des Français
de de
[Applaudissements]
papier ma France elle dit à ceux qu'elle
choisit d'accueillir qu'il n''est nul
besoin que leurs ancêtres aient été à
gergovi à aosterlitz
ou à Verdin pour qu'il se sent
passionnément
français
ma France elle dit aime la France et la
France
[Applaudissements]
t'aimera
je suis une femme
d'ordre je veux la France en ordre car
je veux la France de la Concorde
ordre à nos frontières mais aussi ordre
dans la rue ordre à l'école une France
en désordre c'est quand la loi des
bandes la loi du plus fort se sub au
lois de la République car oui nous en
sommes là ce sont ces checkpoint à
l'entrée de certains quartiers ces tir
de mortiers dans les rues ces
enseignants frappés en pleine classe ces
jeunes filles harcelées qui n'osent plus
porter des jupes pour ne pas subir
l'injure je serai toujours à leur côté
je ne veux plus qu'aucun français aucune
française ne BA les yeux ne rasent les
[Applaudissements]
murs mes amis j'ai été juge j'ai
ressenti la gravité de rendre la justice
au nom du peuple français j'ai vu la
beauté de cette justice qui répare alors
je le dis avec une révolte plus grande
encore nous sommes devenus le pays des
victimes
oubliées l'appauvrissement le
délabrement de notre justice est un
scandale d'État Emmanuel Macron devra
rendre des
comptes si nous ne réagissons pas très
fortement un jour j viendra où les
Français ne vivront plus ensemble mais
face à
face alors je seraiis
indéfectiblement au soutien de nos
forces de
l'ordre j'augmenterai massivement les
moyens de nos tribunaux et de nos
prisons nous simplifierons la procédure
pénale afin de réduire radicalement les
délais de jugement impunité zéro la
sécurité sera pour vous l'insécurité
pour les
voyou je seraiis implacable contre tous
ceux qui s'attaquent à la République
parmi eux les prêcheurs de haine de
l'islamisme ce nouveau totalitarisme il
veut détruire ce que nous sommes et
c'est pour cela que nous nous battrons
pour la
laïcité contre ceux qui veulent imposer
la charia au-dessus de nos lois je
réaffirme que la loi de la République
est au-dessus de la foi et dans la
Constitution nous inscrirons que nul ne
peut se prévaloir de son origine ou de
sa religion pour s'exonérer de la loi
commune
[Applaudissements]
la laïcité est mon combat depuis
toujours il y a 12 ans nous n'étions que
quelques-uns à réclamer l'interdiction
de la burka dans l'espace public nous
avons été les lanceur d'alerte de la
laïcité en Île-de-France j'ai imposé à
toutes les associations qui réclament
des financements la signature de la
première Charte de la laïcité pas 1 €
d'argent public pour les ennemis de la
[Applaudissements]
République et je continue ce combat en
refusant les tenues religieuses comme le
burkini dans les piscines sur ce sujet
la semaine dernière Emmanuel Macron a
failli il a refusé de faire voter
l'interdiction du dans les compétitions
sportives pour moi le voile n'est pas un
vêtement comme les autres ce n'est pas
une prescription religieuse c'est un
signe de soumission de la femme moi
président de la République aucune femme
ne sera soumise je crois à la liberté je
combats l'emprise je préviens je
n'accepterai jamais de soumettre la
République Marianne n'est pas une femme
[Applaudissements]
voilée dans la nouvelle-fance que je
vous propose il y a ce que nous devons
protéger mais il y a aussi ce que nous
devons
reconstruire
reconstruire il faut reconstruire
l'école l'école est la fabrique de la
France elle est aujourd'hui en péril
ouvrons les yeux nous sommes devenus une
nation de l'immobilité sociale et de
profondes inégalités scolairire il faut
si génération à un enfant d'ouvrier pour
devenir
cadre
français vous qui croyez à l'école de la
République
indignez-vous levez-vous pour notre
école parce que c'est l'avenir de nos
enfants nous allons construire la nation
éducative celle du respect du professeur
celle de l'exigence celle de l'égalité
des
chances chaque enfant a en lui un talent
qui nous appartient de révéler uneto
qui peut
briller alors oui le français les
mathématiques seront les deux grandes
causes éducatives de mon quinenard car
il n'y a pas de cause plus noble que de
transmettre les lumières du
savoir et en disant cela je pense à
Samuel
paatti mort d'avoir voulu apprendre à
nos enfants la
liberté
[Applaudissements]
mes chers
compatriotes nous allons également
reconstruire notre modèle de soin car
jamais je ne me résignera à assister
impuissante à la dégradation de notre
système de
santé lui aussi faisait notre fierté il
incarne la solidarité nationale et notre
foi indéfectible dans le progrès et
pourtant pourtant notre hôpital est à
bout de souffle tenu à bout de bras par
des soignants héroïques 5 millions de
Français vivent sans médecins
traitant il ne suffit pas de mettre la
main au portefeuille pour réconforter
nos soignants il faut les toucher au
cœur redonner du sens à leur métier il
faut les
considérer
nous libérerons l'hôpital des
contraintes administratif qui l'étouffe
nous y recruterons 25000 soignants
supplémentaires nous enverrons 4000
docteurs juniors généralistes dans les
territoires qui en manquent je veux que
les français où qu'ils vivent puissent
être soignés sans attendre et prês de
chez
eux
oui nous sauverons nos grands services
publics et il faudra aussi reconstruire
notre
industrie je dénonce cette folie d'une
nation sans
usine
sans sans ingénieur sans
ouvriers partout sur le territoire je
vois la détresse de ces hommes et de ces
femmes dont les usines ferm et
continuent de
délocaliser le gouvernement a beaucoup
parlé mais qu'a-t-il fait
85 milliards d'euros de déficit de la
balance commerciale alors que tous N
ce chiffre dit
tout ce chiffre c'est le drame
français on nira pas vers le plein emplo
sans inventer produire en France verire
le plein emploi seulement avec des
emplois de service on ne fera rien de
grand si nos chercheurs continuent de
s'exiler je crois à l'initiative à ces
étincelles qui sortent des sentier battu
aujourd'hui c'est le règne du
scepticisme des complottismes de la
décroissance le parti de la décroissance
et le parti de l'ignorance moi je crois
au progrès un progrès qui n'est pas
l'ennemi de l'écologie bien au contraire
je veux reconstruire la France de
l'innovation pas la France de la
[Applaudissements]
précaution dans l'espace sous nos m
d'immenses découvertes s encore à nous
sur le quantique sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur les bithèques je nous
veux au premier
la France je la vois à la pointe de
toutes les fulgurances technologiques
scientifiques industriell oui je veux la
France des laboratoires des usines et
pas des friches nous baisserons les
impôts et les charges depuis des
décennies trop d'impôt tu
l'emplois nous devons produire plus
produire mieux produire entre autrement
nous réinventerons une nouvelle
respectueuse de l'homme et de la planète
une nouvelle croissance pour le plein
emploi oui
protégeronstruire mais
c'est ça la Nouvelle France oui mes
chers compatriotes la France de 2030 ne
sera pas celle de 2022 parce qu'après la
crise covid plus rien ne sera comme
avant parce que les Français ont changé
et avec eux leurs aspirations mais cette
France qui change est pleine de
promesses je défends l'identité
française la vraie car la France n'est
pas une nostalgie c'est une énergie
être français ce n'est pas se résigner
c'est se
relever ce qui a été fissuré peut-être
rebâti ce qui est dépassé doit être
réinventé je ferai éclore cette France
nouvelle et avec elle cette créativité
ce génie français qui ont toujours fait
notre
grandeur je veux une société française
[Applaudissements]
libérée
et oui mes chers amis le vrai convoit de
la liberté c'est
[Applaudissements]
nous alors pour cela il faut en finir
avec ces normes qui nous étouffent
enfin normes qui s'empilent et qui
empêche tout projet de voir le jour la
France est une Marianne en corset une
Marianne qui essaie de garder sa
prestance mais qui n'arrive plus à
respirer je veux une société qui donne
sa force aux créateurs aux entrepreneurs
aux courageux qui s'engagent pour vivre
à fond leur rêve
[Applaudissements]
français
c'est un immense chantier qui demandera
beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
Constance car derrière chaque
administration il y a Kafka qui
sommeille ce courage cette constance je
les
[Applaudissements]
ai dans cette nouvelle France il faut
réinventer le travail lui donner du sens
et de la
reconnaissance la crise covid a
bouleversé notre relation au travail
elle a renforcé l'aspiration des
Français à mieux concilier leur vie
personnelle et leur vie professionnelle
pour certains le télétravail en a été
l'opportunité mais une nouvelle fracture
sociale s'est creusée entre ceux qui
peuvent télétravailler et ceux qui ne le
peuvent pas et qui pour certains ont été
touchés de plein fouet par la hausse du
prix de
l'essence avec le retour de l'inflation
trop de Français compte à l'euro près
dès le 10 du mois quand les factures ont
été payé cette France du travail cette
France des rond-points des premiers
métros celle qui est debout aux aurores
cette France essentielle elle est le
cœur battant de la
nouvellefance
je veux que le travail paye qu'il paye
plus que laassistana et surtout qu'il
soit payé à son juste prix je m'y engage
avec moi les salaires des Français
augmenteront de 10 % sur le quinena rien
ne me détournera de cet objectif c'est
une question de justice c'est une
question de dignité et plus encore c'est
dans l'intérêt des entreprises elles le
savent elles cherchent à recruter elles
cherchent à fidéliser leurs salariés et
elle mesurent leur difficultés de vie
quotidienne ainsi dès cet été chaque
salarié gagnant 1400 €
net gagnera 500 € de salaire de plus par
[Applaudissements]
an
je suis la candidate du travail et de la
feuille de
pay souvenez-vous Nicolas Sarkozy avait
eu cette belle intuition travailleer
plus pour gagner
[Applaudissements]
plus moi j'ajoute liberté liberté de
fixer le temps de travail au sein de
l'entreprise il n'y aura plus de plafond
pour la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires les RTT pourront être
transformés en salaire sans plafond ni
charge la participation et
l'intéressement seront exonérés de
forfaits social pour que les entreprises
y aient davantage recours nous
favoriserons l'actionnariat salarié et
nous libérerons totalement le cumul en
[Applaudissements]
retraite pour autant je le dis en
responsabilité il y a deux vérités qu'il
faut entendre et qu'il faut
assumer nous devons travailler plus si
nous voulons être prospère retrouver de
la croissance sauver nos
solidarités et la deuxième vérité c'est
que nous devons dépenser moins et mieux
tout autre discours est
[Musique]
mensonger un pays surendetté est un pays
économiquement faible socialement
suicidaire un pays surendetté et
moralement coupable d'exposer ses
enfants au risque de la
faillite souvenez-vous de
l'avertissement prémonitoire lancé en
responsabilité par François
[Applaudissements]
Fillon et depuis et depuis 1000
milliards de dettes de plus en 10 ans
un/4 dû à la crise covid le reste c'est
de la fuite en
avant
c'est pour cela que nous ferons les
réformes des retraites de l'État et de
l'assurance chômage que ceux qui nous
dirigent n'ont pas eu le courage de
mener dans la Nouvelle-France celui qui
touche le RSA donnera chaque semaine 15
he d'activité à la
[Applaudissements]
société nelle France quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie on a droit à une
retraite digne et indexé sur l'inflation
plus aucun retraité qui a cotisé toute
sa vie ne touchera une retraite
inférieure au SMIC
[Applaudissements]
oui dans cette nouvelle France on
travaillera autrement mais on vivra
aussi autrement après 2 ans ement les
Français se détournent des cœurs de
métropole trop cher trop pollué trop
dens ils demandent de l'air de
l'espace ma nouvelle France ce n'est pas
Paris et le désert français c'est une
France capitale où chaque ville chaque
département chaque région est une pépite
nous allons décentraliser radicalement
le
[Applaudissements]
pays
je mettrai fin à cette présidence
verticale qui méprise les
[Musique]
territoires l'État doit lâcher
prise car les libertés locales
confortent la cohésion nationale elles
font vivre cette solidarité de proximité
auquel les Français sont tant
attachés avec eux je porterai une une
vraie une grande
décentralisation celle de la
simplification et du bon
[Applaudissements]
sens la décentralisation de
l'ingéniosité des territoires de tous
les territoires car elle permettra aussi
à nos outres exprimer pleinement leur
vitalité économique et culturelle nos
outremèes si chè à mon cœur qui font
rayonner la France sur tous les
[Applaudissements]
océans nous devons réinvestir notre
ruralité la ruralité à laquelle je crois
est à l'imimage de la France que je veux
elle est fière elle est audace use elle
est enracinée et conquérante elle donne
le meilleur de son identité en prenant
le meilleur de la
modernité et c'est pour cela que j'ai
pris un engagement quand on investira 1
€ pour la politique de la ville on
investira aussi 1 € pour les territoires
[Applaudissements]
ruraux pour eux nous engagerons un grand
plan d'investissement avec le retour du
TGV mais aussi des lignes régionales
[Applaudissements]
structurantes et pour lutter contre le
mallogement et contre la flambée des
prix je l'assume un rebour de tous les
décroissants il faudra construire plus
et il faudra construire
mieux nous redonnerons du pouvoir au ma
pour CER to où il n'y a plus de mixité
nous redonnerons de la mobilité dans le
parc social et je veux surtout porter
cet immense espoir d'une France de
propriétaire qui est le projet d'une
[Applaudissements]
vie et
puis solidarité
familiale je crois à la
famille chaque fois qu'un couple se
forme que des enfants naissent la vie
est là plus forte que
l'adversité la famille est le socle sur
lequel tout repose la famille c'est le
lieu de la transmission et des valeurs
le partage l'honnêteté le civisme elle
protège des accidents de la vie et puis
elle apporte cette tendresse N sont
privés tant de nos concitoyens frappés
par la
solitude je serai la candidate des
familles et je sens bien que je serai la
seule car François Hollande et Emmanuel
Macron affaibli les Familles de France
ils ont réduit la politique familiale à
une politique
sociale nous rétablirons l'universalité
des allocations familiales nous
reconstruirons une vraie
FAM celle du Front populaire celle du
général de
[Applaudissements]
Gaulle ma nouvelle France c'est celle
qui assume d'encourager la transmission
[Applaudissements]
95 % des Français seront exonérés de
droit de succession pour pouvoir
transmettre à leurs enfants le fruit
d'une vie de travail et NOTAM le de
[Applaudissements]
famille enfin je serai résolument au
côté de ces mes seules sur lesquels la
vie a fait reposer tant de
responsabilités les pensions
alimentaires qu'elles touchent pour
leurs enfants seront exonéré
d'impôt
oui je crois à la famille je défendrai
toutes les famille mais avec une ligne
rouge je m'opposerai toujours à la GPA
car il s'agit d'une marchandisation du
corps de la femme pour moi le corps
d'une femme ne s'achète pas ne se loue
[Applaudissements]
pas
le sens de la famille c'est aussi le
droit d'aller embrasser nos aînés et
d'accompagner nos proches dans les
derniers instants quelle que soit
l'urgence
sanitaire ce droit les Français n'en
seront plus jamais
[Applaudissements]
privés
et je le dis avec gravité je ne fermerai
pas les yeux sur la situation dans
certains
épades comme vous j'ai été révolté de
découvrir ces exploiteurs de la
fragilité humaine comment sommes-nous
arrivés
là les sanctions devront tomber et elles
devront être exemplaire tout le
fonctionnement et le contrôle du système
sera
[Applaudissements]
revu dans ma nouvelle- France nous
mettrons la dignité humaine au-dessus de
tout chacun est unique jusqu'à son
dernier souffle et c'est pour cela que
je donnerai la priorité au maintien à
domicile de nos aînés et que je
renforcerai le statut de nos aidants
familiaux car il leur apporte
l'inestimable
l'affection cette même affection que
nous devons à nos compatriotes en
situation de handicap car oui la
vulnérabilité fait partie de la vie oui
notre société doit tendre la main au
plus fragile et elle doit tirer sa force
de nos
[Applaudissements]
différence différents mes chers
compatriotes vous l'êtes tous par vos
origines par vos croyances par votre
identité tous différents mais tous digne
d'un même respect dans ma France il n'y
aura jamais des gens qui ne sont rien je
serai la président de tous les
[Applaudissements]
Français
président
président Président mes chers
compatriotes vous êtes en droit de
savoir qui je
suis je suis né un 14
juillet ce jour de fête nationale où la
France se rassemble et célèbre en même
temps la prise de la Bastille et la fête
de la Fédération
la Révolution et la réconciliation
nationale enfant je ne manquais jamais
un défilé militaire j'aimais
particulièrement le palent de la légion
à l'histoire si romanesque et héroïque
j'écoutais mes grands-parents et mes
oncles me raconter leur engagement dans
la Résistance et puis
oui depuis
l'enfance la France coule dans mes
veines la France des balles populaires
des feux d'artifice et du Tour de
[Applaudissements]
France
fille de
prof mon père était le 7e enfant d'un
Mercier bonnetier de GAAP monté à Paris
pour devenir professeur
d'université il un vrai parcours
républicain il m'a donné cet amour de la
France mais aussi le goût du travail et
de la lecture alors à cette époque-là le
mot héros s'érivait pas au féminin je ne
me reconnaissais ni en Miled ni en
Roxane et encore moins en madame bovar
moi j'étais d'Artagnan j'étais Cano
j'étais le Hussard sur le
[Applaudissements]
toit
singulier ma mère était l'assistante de
mon grand-père psychiatre après l'école
il me parlait de ses patients de leurs
angoisses de leurs souffran lui qui
réparait les âmes et parfois sans
succès il m'a appris à regarder et à
respecter la fragilité qui existe en
chacun d'entre
nous
alors c'est vrai je n'ai pas rêvé enfant
de devenir présidente de la
République mais à l'époque qui l'aurait
imaginé et pourtant je ne suis pas
devant vous par
hasard c'est vrai que pour devenir qui
je suis j'ai dû bousculer j'ai dû
prendre mon destin en main décider de
quitter la voie tracée de la finance
pour choisir le service de l'État
oui je voulais donner un supplément
d'âme à ma vie je suis donc devenu juge
au Conseil d'État juge pour dire le
droit mais juge aussi pour défendre les
victimes à cette époque je vivais la vie
des jeunes femmes d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui avec ses promesses
d'émancipation mais aussi ses
humiliation subie en silence celle de se
voir refuser deux emplois parce que
j'étais enceinte celle du harcèlement
des petits chefs celle des frotteurs du
métro celle des agressions
sexuelles mais ma volonté était intacte
personne ne me ferait baisser les yeux
personne ne doit plus nous faire baisser
les
[Applaudissements]
yeux
je n'ai hérité d'aucun poste d'aucun
parti tout ce que j'ai obtenu je l'ai
gagné j'ai rejoint Jacques Chirac à
l'Élysée au lendemain de la dissolution
ratée de 1997 quand il était seul et
abandonné c'était un suicide
professionnel qu'importe moi j'y croyais
j'étais à contre-courant libre
déjà ensuite en 2002 après la victoire
de Chirac j'ai choisi de soumettre au
suffrage des Français dans un combat que
les sondeurs disaient perdu
d'avance me faire élire aller au contact
des Français puiser dans leur confiance
ma légitimité me mettre à leur service
écrire de nouvelle loi pour changer la
vie la politique la vraie est devenue
passion de jacquesirac j'ai beaucoup
appris
l'écoute l'empathie mais aussi et encore
l'amour de cette France de Paris et des
campagnes mêlé nous partagions l'amour
de la corise de cette corise de granit
et d'ardoise devenue il y a 27 ans ma
terre d'adoption et mon
refuge en politique j'ai eu aussi une
marine de cœur Madame Simon
veille
elle m'a prise sous son aile quand jeune
député je suis arrivée à l'Assemblée
elle m'a guidé et soutenu dans mes
campagnes je lu vousoue une infinie
reconnaissance ces combats sont devenus
les miens et j'ai où qu'ell soit une
pensée particulière pour elle
aujourd'hui
et il y a eu Nicolas
Sarkozy son audace sa force sa vision il
m'a donné cette chance unique d'être
ministre de la
République ministre de la réforme la
plus explosive de son gouvernement alors
pour la fille de prof que j'étais quel
plus beau défi donner à notre jeunesse
une université digne d'elle capable de
avec les plus belles Fages du
monde mais cela a été dur très dur 9
mois de manif mes enfants harcelés à
l'école par des militants extrémistes
agressé sur les réseaux sociaux par des
avatars qu'il
pcress mais dans l'épreuve je suis S et
je tiens la réforme est passée personne
n'a osé revenir dessus mais personne non
plus n'a eu le courage de la poursuivre
moi je la poursuivrai
[Applaudissements]
ensuite ensuite vint le temps de la
défaite des doutes des questionnements
au régional puis au président
C c'est vrai qu'on apprend plus de ces
échecs que de ces victoires et surtout
on apprend à se
relever c'est pour cela que dans ma
France je veux que tous ceux qui échoue
se voit attendre une main fraternelle si
vous avez échoué c'est d'abord que vous
avez
[Applaudissements]
tenté
mais j'ai décidé que ma région ma belle
région était trop mal en point pour la
laisser en plan et j'ai construit un
autre projet pour elle je me suis battu
et je me bats
encore je suis cette femme française
indomptable que rien n'arrête quand elle
sent qu'il faut se lever pour défendre
ses convictions et ses
compatriote et je le dis aujourd'hui
rien ne
[Applaudissements]
m'arrêtera il paraît que les famillees
heureuses n'ont pas d'histoire alors
heureuse la mienne le fut mais avec ses
é preuve de la vie que toute famille
doit surmonter
elle a aussi reçu des coups d'une rare
violence des coups qui en réalité m'étai
destiné alors ces cicatrices je ne vous
en parlerai pas parce qu'elles
n'appartiennent qu'à moi et au
mien avec cette pudeur je ne transigerai
pas car c'est ma façon de protéger ce
auquel je tiens le plus et je sais que
vous me
comprendrez mais ces épreuves elles
m'ont fait murir
elles ont renforcé cette part
d'humanité sans laquelle il n'existe pas
de vrais
chef
alors mes chers amis je n'aurais jamais
fait tout ce chemin sans le soutien et
l'amour de Jérôme mon
mari et de mes enfants Baptiste Clément
et
[Applaudissements]
Émilie
27 ans d'amour comme dirait Brel c'est
l'amour
folle merci
gérô et merci à vous les enfants je suis
si fire de ce que vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
devenus vous l'avez compris mes chers
compatriotes j'ai eu dans ma vie ma part
de
chance mais mes parents et mes maîtres
m'ont appris que quand on a beaucoup
reçu il faut beaucoup donner et
aujourd'hui
je veux donner sa part de chance à
chaque enfant de
[Applaudissements]
France c'est à vous que je m'adresse
maintenant jeunesse de
France
la jeunesse de France celle qui veut
vivre libre et vivre à fond je vous
aiderai à prendre votre envol et je le
dis à tous les jeunes de France soyez
rebelles ne tombez jamais dans
l'autocensure ne doutez pas votre
jeunesse est une promesse battez-vous
pour avoir cette chance d'avoir 20 ans
dans un pays libre et encore puissant
soyez la génération tricolore
fraternelle et audacieuse celle qui file
vers de nouvelles espérances celle qui
éveille nos consciences et qui se bat
pour sauver la planète celle qui part à
l'assaut du monde en maîtrisant tous les
langages vous êtes la France de demain
cette nouvelle- France elle est pour
vous
va on va gag on va gagner on va gag on
va gagner on va gagner on va gagner on
va gag on va G on va G on va G on va g
mes chers
compatriotes il est temps il est temps
de vous g il est temps de reconstruire
il est temps de nous réinventer il est
temps de vous respecter il est temps de
réconcilier les Français il est temps
d'écrire une nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
page il nous reste 2 mois faites
raisonner partout le nom de notre pays
car c'est le nom d'un grand peuple c'est
le nom d'une belle identité la
nouvelle-fance c'est le nom d'une
promesse celle d'aimer la France de
toutes nos
[Applaudissements]
forces les extrémistes vous mentent
refusez le venin de la nostalgie ne
laissez ni la colère ni la peur
l'emporter j'incarne avec vous la
République en ordre ils sont le désordre
j'incarne la force de l'unité nationale
ils sont la
désunion contre cet extrémisme
choisissez la mains ferme et
[Applaudissements]
juste
et contre
l'immobilisme choisissez
[Applaudissements]
l'action sur les chemins de la victoire
nous allons nous lever nous allons iser
nos
drapeaux la France demande du courage ce
courage je
l'ai
alors
debout nous allons ouvrir toutes ces
bastilles qui nous tiennent à l'ombre
vous êtes fait pour la lumière vous êtes
fait pour la grandeur nous sommes là
ensemble pour affirmer haut et fort que
la Nouvelle France
arrive la France de toujours et du futur
la France éternelle et nouvelle qui
renoue avec son
épopé ce nom de France je veux qu'il
raisonne de nouveau je veux qu'il étonne
je veux qu'il tonne êtes-vous prêt à
vous lancer
êtes-vous prêt à traverser les
tempêtes à soulever les montagnes
êtes-vous prêt à foncer pour la
victoire moi je le suis alors suivez-moi
vive la république et vive la
France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà vous avez pu suivre donc en direct
le meeting de Valérie PCRs le discours a
duré un petit peu plus longtemps que que
prévu euh on va y revenir ensemble vous
avez été nombreux à commenter peut-être
déjà une précision vous dire que il y
avait beaucoup plus de monde que ne
pouvait en contenir la salle on a
atteint presque les 8000 assistants à ce
à ce meeting alors que la la salle du
zénite ne pouvait en contenir que 7000
maximum et la des salles ont été une
salle a été ouverte pour que d'autres
personnes puissent suivre ce meeting que
vous avez été nombreux à suivre en
direct on a vu vos commentaires on a vu
vos réactions moi je vous propose
d'écouter celle de rodolp et d'Isabelle
qui ont assisté à ce meeting bonjour
bonjour Est-ce que vous avez été
convaincu par Valérie pcrè qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de ce meeting de ce
meeting comment vous vous l'avez vécu
ben moi j'étais très convaincu et
surtout j'attendais ce meeting avec
impatience parce que je trouvais que
Valérie elle sillonne la France mais
elle parlait pas beaucoup d'un point de
vue national c'est beaucoup bah ces
concurrents qui sont qui sont mis à la
tête d'affiche des journaux notamment et
là vraiment voilà c'est un grand
soulagement on la voit naturelle elle
nous convain tout le monde est autour
d'elle il manque plus qu'une personne
c'est Nicolas Sarkozi alors on l'attend
très vite Nicolas faut vite n prouver
rodolp comment vous avez vécu cette ce
ce meeting il y a beaucoup de réactions
parmi les internautes qui ne trouvent
pas Valérie PCR très très naturel un peu
statique est-ce que c'est votre
sentiment alors non je l'ai trouvé au
contraire
très très très très humaine très directe
très franche et très très clair dans ses
propos et surtout comme Isabelle j'aiété
absolument donc c'était un très très
beau très très beau myting très très
beau discours et j'ai trouvé très très
très agréable de l'avoir entouré de tout
de toutes les équipes LR sauf Nicolas
Sarkozi évidemment mais c'était c'était
très bien très beau elle m'a oui
convaincu qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué dans ce discours moi je pense que
c'est sa franchise son honnêteté
voilà je la trouve naturelle et donc
c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup marqué
et puis je la connais depuis très
longtemps c'est quand même notre
présidente en Île-de-France c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup bouger les
lignes nous nous sommes entrepreneurs
d'une toute petite entreprise vraiment
on voit que la région se pousse et nous
pousse à embaucher nous aide et c'est un
vrai soutien donc voilà moi je suis
voilà je suis convaincu mais déjà
d'avance beaucoup de l'accent a été
beaucoup mis sur la sécurité et sur sur
imigration Valérie P a même employé le
terme de de grand remplacement comment
vous réagissez par rapport à à ces
thématique et à l'emploi de ces
thématique par Valérie PCR je TR encore
une fois je l'ai trouvé très très juste
dans ses dans ses propos dans ses
analyse et peut-être plus plus crédiible
que des discours qu'on entend sur ces
sujets là notamment chezic Zemour et et
Marine Le Pen qui sont peut-être moins
crédibles parce que trop trop trop fort
trop extrémiste peut-être et je pense
que avec Valérie pcrè il y aura un
soutien parce qu'on pense à la
présidentielle mais n'oublions pas les
législatifes qui auront lieu un mois
après et il est très important qu'il y
ait une majorité
législative parlementaire après sinon
rien ne pourra se faire et et et et
voilà merci beaucoup et bon retour donc
à à champign et merci d'avoir réagi en
direct sur le site du Figaro euh Albane
je vous propose avant de prendre les
commentaires des des internautes et bien
d'avoir l'analyse de de Lur Salvin de
Cantard lur qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
frappé qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué dans ce
discours alors ce qui m'a marqué c'est
la la diversité des thèmes qui ont été
abordés Valérie PCR a voulu se présenter
comme une femme politique qui
connaissait les Français de par
notamment ses sa famille son ancrage
familial elle a parlé de son grand-père
psychiatre qui essayait de penser les
des Français donc grande diversité des
sujets abordés une certaine stature
aussi elle n'a pas effectivement
certains ont pu lui reprocher d'être
très statique et en même temps elle a
voulu montrer qu'elle était bien ancrée
dans le territoire français qu'elle
était stable qu'elle avait le courage
d'y aller elle a utilisé beaucoup aussi
de de symboliqu forte hein elle a parlé
de femmes fortes Angela Merker toucher
elle s'est également mis sous le signe
de Simone veille effectivement on sait
que ce sont des des personnalités
politiques qui sont particulièrement
bien qui sont particulièrement appréciés
par par les Français ce qui m'a marqué
aussi c'est la volonté de
de d'audace en fait de sortir un petit
peu
des des des sentiers battu d'innover et
puis enfin elle a beaucoup parlé de sa
France à elle de la France qu'elle
qu'elle appréciait une France assez
traditionnelle dans ses mots une France
tournée autour des familles de l'Union
et puis effectivement de
l'identité française alors pendant qu'on
se parle et pendant que vous parliez
justement il y avait ah ben il est en
train de partir le président de de l'uni
jackques Smith qui qui était présent on
lui demandera peut-être également ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a pensé de de ce de ce
discours est-ce que vous avez été vous
surprise
sur l'emplo d'un certain nombre de
thématiqu et en particulier dans tout le
début discours du discours de thémati
voisine qu'on peut entendre dans les
discours d'é Zemour et de Marine Le Pen
je n'ai pas été surprise parce que ça
fait partie des préoccupation prioritair
des Français l'immigration la
laïcité l'intégration et puis le fait
aussi de parler de l'islam je crois que
pendant longtemps ça a été un non sujet
en fait parce qu'on ne sait pas comment
l'aborder les Français aujourd'hui
demandent à ce que ce soit un sujet dont
on discute donc ce n'est pas un sujet
qui m'a étonné de la part de Valérie PC
ce qui m'a davantage étonné c'est la
place qu'elle a accordé à l'éducation
dans son dans son meeting elle a parlé
aux jeunes elle a essayé de les attirer
vers elle en leur parlant d'avenir aussi
et donc de l'importance qu'elle accordé
dans son programme à l'éducation des
enfants et des jeunes enfants français
Alban on va revenir à
au commentairire des des
internautes vous les avez suivi pendant
tout le pendant tout le meeting on va
les écoutez je vous propose que vous les
partagiez avec nous et puis on va
essayer de de parler àir des des
militants vous voyez que il y a
l'occasion pour certains de faire de de
se prendre en photo à côté de moiz même
un militant qui vient de la corise qui
est
donc de jairac la terre d'élection de
François Holland aussi et là où Valérie
PC passe une partie de ses vacances et
elle a bien s évoqué au cours de ce
discours vous avez dû l'entendre vous
avez dû l'entendre elle a évoqué la
corise qui est donc la la terre
d'origine de la famille de son
mari c'est quelle chaîne c'est quelle
oui tout à fait Vincent d'ailleurs les
internautes ont été en revanche assez
sévères vis-à-vis de Valérie PC vous
l'avez dit ils ont été nombreux à
commander le discours de de Valérie pcrè
pendant pendant 1h 1h3 ils se sont ils
ont étit nombreux à alimenter le chat et
je vous lis certaines réactions je vous
lisais assez sévère euh certains parlent
de Titanic en direct de moment de
malaise euh beaucoup ont souligné le
caractère peu spontané et très écrit du
discours de Valérie pcrè je cite il il
critique qu'il n'y ait aucun aucun
lirisme elle récite sa liste de courses
c'est vide euh n'est absolument pas
habité par ses idées donc voilà c'est ce
qui ressort essentiellement des des
différents des différents commentaires
euh du Chat du Figaro c'est vrai
que ce qui ressort derrière l'analyse
alors je vous laisse vincant la parole
puisque je vois que vous êtes accompagné
d'un
militant ah ben on va justement puisque
les les les appréciations du chats sont
assez sévères on va demander justement à
ce militant j'ai pas je vous ai pas
demandé votre prénom Sébastien sastien
Sébastien il y a beaucoup de de
commentaires dans le chat du du Figaro
actuellement qui trouvent que Valé PC a
manqué peut-être de naturel dans son
discours est-ce que c'est ce que vous
avez ressenti non du tout j'ai pas du
tout ressenti ce ce naturel au début on
pourrait croire mais faut faut être sur
la longueur et lors de tout le meeting
non du tout faut écouter
tout deout de bout en bout voilà
galvanisé vraiment moi moi ce qui m'a
marqué elle a parlé de tout ce qui était
famille
les enfants la
santé et puis B la reconstruction du
pays tout ce qui est industrie et autres
vraiment sur des points clés et comme
elle gère déjà plus de 30 % du pays je
trouve qu'elle fait le job c'est pour ça
que la soutiens qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses qui
vous ont marqué dans les thématiques
qu'elle dans les thèmes qu'elle a abordé
dans le discours dans le discours le
thématique santé
retraite les droits aussi de succession
ben relever le pays au niveau industriel
et et et lancer sa dynamique parce qu'
elle le sait elle sait le faire ça fait
ça fait un paquet d'années qu'elle est
dans la partie et elle gère plus de 30 %
du pays donc vous repartez convaincu
vous pensez que la dynamique est parti
tout à fait pour moi oui et tous ceux
qui sont justement dans le doute ou ou
pas dans ses idées ben je les invite à à
écouter dans la longueur hein avant de
se faire juste un avis sur certains faut
écouter un peu tout le monde et et dans
le l'eau je trouve qu'elle se démarque
beaucoup parce qu'elle fait le job je le
redis elle gère quand même plus de 30 %
des pays par rapport à nos anciens de
l'île-de-fance hein pour passité il y a
une grosse avancée quand on prend les
transports en commun la voiture et are
la notion des problématiques de vie elle
est pas hors se merci merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi en direct
sur le site du Figaro moi je pense en
vous écoutant Alban et en voyant
effectivement avec vous les les
commentaires qu'il y avaent pendant le
chat c'est intéressant d'avoir justement
le ressenti qu'il y a je en parler on en
parlait avec avec l'UR ce qui est vrai
c'est que la il y avait quand même une
forme de ferveur dans la dans la salle
en tous les cas il y avait une chaleur
il y avait une ambiance dans la salle
tout à fait effectivement il y avait une
grande ambiance on avait l'impression
que justement à babord comme à tribor on
essayait de de de de
remporter à celui qui ferait le plus de
bruit ce qui m'a marqué aussi dans
pendant ce ce meeting c'est que Val
s'est adressé à plusieurs reprises à
Emmanuel Macron elle a vraiment
identifié comme son adversaire principal
elle a pas fait état des autres
candidats et je pense que ni er Zemour
ni Marine Le Pen on nt été cité un peu
allusion à la fin quand elle critique
les nostalgiques tout à fait des
allusions mais jamais
desidentification elle a vraiment voulu
se présenter comme la candidate la plus
crédible la plus compétente aussi pour
faire face à Emmanuel
on va continuer à à essayer de chercher
un certain nombre de de militants qui
sont ici voyez on a derrière nous
d'ailleurs des chaînes américaines qui
sont installé qui interrogent les les
militants pour avoir leur leur résultat
leur réaction pardon il y avait d'autres
il y a d'autres élus également que que
l'on voit on va essayer de les on va
essayer de les contacter on va essayer
de leur demander leur leur réaction
pendant ce tempsl ah tiens on va
demander peut-être à Jacques Smith de
l'unici va venir nous parler vraiment
pas vous avez qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé vous êtes en direct ben bonjour à
tous bonjour à
tous qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez justement du du
discours beaucoup ont été en tout cas ce
qui a été ce qui a surpris ça a été
toute la partie en tout cas ce qui a été
remarqué c'est la partie sur l'
enseignement supérieur euh quelle est la
situation justement dans l'enseignement
supérieur aujourd'hui Valée PCR a dit
que elle avait commencé une réforme et
qu'elle allait la continuer de quoi
s'agit-il exactement ben l'objectif elle
a commencé elle a commencé à le dire
c'est c'est surtout le fléo du wisme et
de l'islamghuchisme qui gangraine
l'ensemble de nos université et
l'ensemble de l'enseignement supérieur
et et aujourd'hui c'est vraiment l'enjeu
et donc il faudra des mesures fortes
pour lutter contre cette gang graine
justement qui qui qui est vraiment le
fléo et le et un péril morê puisqu'on
parle de des jeunes et donc de l'avenir
de notre de notre pays quoi est-ce qu'il
y a des mesures dans le programme de de
Valérie pcrè en tous les cas qui vont
dans le sens aussi d'une amélioration du
niveau de l'université ah bah sur toutes
les valeurs du Mérite du travail de
l'effort de la récompense c'est sûr que
c'est les valeurs de la droite qu'on a
envie de voir porter par une candidate
de droite et aujourd'hui il faudra
effectivement que Valérie PCR puisse euh
continuer ce qu'elle dit et mettre en
application ce qu'elle dit là-dessus
pour que enfin à l'université le mérite
a toute sa place parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand on dit méritocratie dans
université française on est un peu
regardé avec des gros yeux et c'est ça
et c'est ça qui a un peu le le le le
gros danger de l'université merci
beaucoup jacqu d'avoir réagi en direct
et d'avoir surmonté votre timidité
naturelle lor précisément cette
interpellation des
jeunes qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire et
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé justement
dans cette séquence ah non mais s'il
plaît c'est important de de s'adresser
aux jeunes et notamment après la période
difficile aussi qu'ils ont passé pendant
toute cette crise covid c'est vrai que
on a beaucoup entendu parler de ces
jeunes qui sont retouvés dans la
solitude qui ont eu du mal à suivre leur
cours aussi et et Valérie PC a voulu
s'adresser à eux pour leur dire aussi
que ils avaient les clés quelque part de
l'avenir de la France que c'était sur
eux que la France comptait que les
citoyens français compté c'est important
de s'adresser aussi à cette population
là parce que c'est la population
finalement la moins sûre de de se
déplacer et d'aller voter pour le le
premier tour notamment de l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que c'est aussi un
enjeu aussi pour les les républicains
qui a traditionnellement du mal avec
cette ce segment de
l'électorat l'électorat républicain est
plutôt un un électorat plutôt senior
l'électorat républicain effectivement
est un électorat plutôt senior de
retraiter retraiter d'ailleurs cadre ou
employés ouvrier hein c'est pas il y a
pas de différenciation c'est assez
marquant dans les enquête que l'on peut
réaliser alors l'électorat jeune c'est
l'électorat que tout le monde que tout
candidat essaie de comment dire de
mobiliser mais c'est un électorat très
très difficile à mobiliser que ce soit
pour les républicains traditionnellement
mais aussi pour les autres candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ce sont des
jeunes qui ne se sentent pas forcément
bien compris et là à plusieurs reprises
valériie pcrress a dit entendre ces
jeunes et a dit comprendre ses jeunes
elle a notamment dans son discours euh
fait référence à de nombreux objets
symboliques du quotidien par exemple la
feuille de salaire elle a parlé de voilà
de choses vraiment de de de carcan aussi
à un moment donné carcan administratif
en début d'année je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez on on on on disait que
finalement ce qui embêtait le plus et ce
qui préoccupait plus le les Français
aujourd'hui c'était euh toutes les
soucis administratifs toute la paperasse
administrative et toutes les normes dont
don dont souffre la société française et
effectivement là Valérie PC en a parlé
et je pense que ça ça ça a fait écho
notamment chez les jeunes merci pour ces
éages lors Albane est-ce que il y a
d'autres questions qui sont posées dans
le chat d'autres commentaires on va
peut-être demander à ces à ces à ces
militants on a des militants à côté de
nous on va leur demander s'ils sont prê
à réagir en direct sur le site du
Figaro ça va très bien se passer vous
inquiétez
pas qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé du du
discours de Val PC est-ce que vous avez
été convaincu moi j'ai été convaincu
personnellement je suis chez les jeunes
républicains donc je milite pour Madame
PCR pour la campagne de de
2022 j'ai été oui bien sûr que j'ai été
convaincue par son discours elle elle
reprend ses propositions qui sont dans
dans son
programme et puis c'est bien parce que
que elle a pu nous les énoncer de vive
voix et j'ai trouvé ça très convainquant
par quoi vous avez été le plus convaincu
vous en tant que militante qu'est-ce que
vous vous
dites pardon euh où atelle était la
meilleure cet après-midi c'est une bonne
question enfin vous voulez dire dans les
dans les thèmes c'est ça dans les thèmes
les thèmes euh moi j'aime beaucoup son
programme sur l'éducation sur l'école je
trouve qu'il est il est pertinent il est
fort qu'est-ce qui vous convainc dans
son programme sur l'école je pense que
aujourd'hui l'école elle elle est pas
elle est pas en bon niveau elle est pas
à son niveau qu'elle a pu avoir dans le
passé et euh c'est ces mesures pour moi
permettront aux enfants notamment rien
que déjà à la primaire et puis ensuite
au collège au lycée déjà en primaire
pour pour pouvoir leur permettre de
d'être meilleur en français en
mathématique ensuite au collège avoir un
un un test en 6 pour savoir si ils sont
ils sont capables d'être en 6e comme les
autres ou alors s'ils ont besoin de
renforcer certaines bases et ensuite
mettre le
le pression sur le fait que partir dans
dans un lycée professionnel c'est c'est
c'est très bien et c'est d'ailleurs
nécessaire on trouve en tous les cas ce
qui a été dit beaucoup de
commentaires même sur le sur le site du
Figaro sur le en tout cas sur Figaro
live on trouvait que Valérie PCR
manquait de naturel dans son dans son
discours dans la façon de le faire
est-ce que ça ça vous a marqué
aujourd'hui alors moi aujourd'hui pas du
tout j'ai trouvé qu'elle était très
naturelle je l'ai trouvé très à l'aise
et je pense que la l'ambiance de la
salle l'a beaucoup aidé notamment chez
les jeunes mais non moi je suis pas
d'accord avec vous je trouvé très
naturel aujourd'hui voilà et qu'est-ce
que vous avez à dire justement à ceux
qui ne la trouvent pas naturelle
bien je sais pas moi c'est qu'est-ce que
j'ai à leur
dire je leur demande qu'est-ce qui vous
fait qu'est-ce qui fait penser que
justement vous avez une perception
aujourd'hui qu'elle était naturelle bien
je trouvais que déjà elle n'a pas lu
elle n'a pas baissé sa tête elle elle
parlait elle parlait absolument mais
c'était quand même très fluide c'était
fluide et avait pas de moment de de
latence elle était toujours je TR
qu'elle elle était ancrée dans ses ses
positions et puis non moi je l'ai trouvé
très convaincante et ça m'a pas j'ai
trouvé convaincante merci beaucoup merci
pour avoir répondu en direct sur le site
du figarou on va peut-être regarder on
va peut-être continuer avec justement
leur Salvin et Daphné caravaka à
regarder et à à vous donner un petit peu
un aperçu de de l'ambiance d'après
meeting de ces instants effectivement de
des suites pour vous rendre compte un
petit peu de qui est là qui est qui est
venu de
l'assistance l'ambiance qui se laquelle
que l'on sent et que l'on
ressent ici donc après le après le
meeting Alban est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions d'autres commentaires avant
peut-être que l'on conclue
oui Vincent il y a une autre question
qui est revenue plusieurs fois dans le
chat du Figaro ou plutôt une réaction
plusieurs internautes nous ont dit je
comprends mieux pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozi
hésite à soutenir Valérie pécr alors
peut-être pouvez-vous demander à à lor
Salvin pourquoi l'ancien chef de l'État
n'a toujours pas déclaré formalement son
soutien à Valérie pécr qu'est-ce que
voilà qu'est-ce qui lui fait défaut pour
avoir ce soutien aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est nécessaire aussi à sa
candidature alors sachant que Valérie
pcrè a rencontré Nicolas Sarkozi
vendredi la conversation a duré pendant
1 he et qu dans les glcaux de l'ancien
président de la République rue
à
Paris la question qui est posée par les
internautes actuellement l c'est
pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozi ne soutient pas
plus ne soutient pas Valé P ne la
soutient pas plus ne soutient pas
explicitement ne vient pas moi j'aurais
une question subsidiaire c'est est-ce
que un soutien affiché l'affichage d'un
soutien par Nicolas sarzi peut créer une
dynamique dans
l'électorat alors Mo je pense que la
question c'est pas tant le soutien de
Nicolas Sarkozi que le non soutien à
l'heure actuelle du du du de l'ancien
président de la République Mo je pense
que c'est un soutien qui serait très
symbolique pour l'actuelle candidate
faut pas oublier que Nicolas Sarkozi
n'est pas non plus le personnage préféré
des Français alors y compris auprès de
son électorat il est encore très
populaire mais valérie pcrè est plutôt
dans de bonne une bonne dynamique auprès
de l' lectura des républicains donc ce
qui est plutôt gênant c'est
effectivement qu'il ne prennent pas la
parole et qui ne donne pas sa position
cette attente est un peu particulière et
d'ailleurs les militants se demandent
effectivement on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure he pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozi
n'intervient pas davantage de là à
penser que ça créerait une dynamique au
sein de célectorat de son électorat je
pense que c'est c'est c'est plus l'enjeu
aujourd'hui l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment d'aller chercher des électeurs
hésitants des électeurs qui voilà hésite
entre Emmanuel Macron et Valérie pcrè ou
peut-être aussi entre Éric Zemour Marine
Le Pen et Valérie pcrè euh vis-à-vis de
cet électorat de droite est-ce que vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui elle a marqué des
points je pense qu'elle a marqué des
points parce que c'était un meeting qui
était attendu on l'attendait sur la
présentation de sa vision et clairement
elle a parlé de sa vision de la France
de sa vision de l'avenir de la France
aussi on avait demandé on en parlait au
au début de l'émission de se dévoiler un
peu elle a un peu dévoilé euh une partie
de son intimité mais très peu et tout en
affirmant qu'effectivement ce n'était
pas non plus son registre et que ce
n'était pas dans son naturel de ce de ce
est-ce qu'il y a pas un autre justement
un autre trait de personnalité sur
lequel peut-être elle pourrait
capitaliser qui est en train
d'apparaître surtout dans ses références
on le disait tout à l'heure à margarette
toucher c'est la femme de faire alors
elle c'est fa mais quand elle dit
concernant la la loi sur les universités
j'ai eu le courage de le faire mais
personne n'a eu le courage de continuer
je le continuerai est-ce que et même en
parlant parfois en assumant une forme
d'impopularité peut-être qu'il y a pas
quelque chose euh en tout cas qui peut
imprimer euh dans ce registre- là auprès
de l'électorat la dame de fer
effectivement et la dame du fer c'est
vrai que cette électoral là est très en
attente de fermeté notamment en matière
d'immigration en matière de sécurité en
matière aussi de laïcité fermeté et en
même temps elle l'a euh réaffir
à plusieurs reprises l'attente d'être
compris aussi par les écouté par les
hommes politiques ce que les hommes et
les femmes politiques ce qu'attendent
les Français c'est de la transparence et
elle effectivement pendant son son
discours elle a essayé de mettre en
avant justement et bien des discours de
vérité ou pas des des arguments
effectivement qu'elle a qu'elle a
souhaité pousser mettre en avant
particulièrement en tout cas c'est vrai
que c'est une belle analogie la dame de
fer et la dame du fer
pareil en écoutant des militants ici qui
qui habitent dans la région Île-deFrance
il nous disaent effectivement que tous
les jours ils seront des comptes des
petits entrepreneurs tous les jours ils
se rendaient compte à quel point Valérie
PCR faisait pour pour eux et faisait
dans dans leur région merci beaucoup l
on va peut-être regarder de nouveau un
petit peu comment ça se passe dans la à
l'intérieur de la salle s'il reste
encore du monde si les militants
essayent de
rencontrer des élus alors il faut savoir
que nous étions au niveau de la sortie
des des militants nous étions pas au
niveau de la la sortie des des élus de
ce que nous voyons effectivement la
salle du zénite se vide il y avait quand
même énormément de monde c'est ça aussi
c'est aussi qu'on peut
qu'on peut c'est aussi ça qu'on peut
retenir cet après-midi c'est qu'il y
avait énormément de énormément de monde
alors je crois que ça en train decrocher
on est en train de retrouver de reculer
pour retrouver les images voilà et on
peut admirer l'exercice auquel s'est
prêté lor
Salvin qui a accepté de
délaisser famille et bureaux de Cantard
pour pouvoir se rendre sur le terrain
alors Albane s'il y a encore des
questions et des commentaires on en
prend quelquesuns et puis on y répondra
avant de conclure oui Vincent il y a une
dernière remarque qui ressort plusieurs
fois dans le chat des internautes du
Figaro l'idée
Val faire de son image de de alors je
cite de bourgeoise français est-ce que
cette image qui lui colle à la peau
pourrait lui faire défaut pendant sa
campagne il lui a fait défaut
aujourd'hui pendant le
meeting alors il y a une image
comment texto on dit de un peu
bourgeoise de Valérie
PCR est-ce que ça peut lui nuire auprès
de l'électorat est-ce que ça peut lui
nuire auprès de l'électorat populaire ou
bien est-ce que ça peut être un atout
dans l'image et dans le le récit d'une
personnalité
gestionnaire alors parle d'image
bourgeoise moi j'ai plutôt trouvé
qu'elle montrait une image de
technicienne de connaisseuse elle
connaît son territoire elle connaît les
Français je pense que les Français
n'attendent pas justement qu'on oppose
bourgeoisie prolétar
ouvrier cadre et cetera et là elle a
voulu se présenter comme la candidate de
tous les Français justement elle a fait
référence à de nombreuses figures aussi
populaires elle a rappelé ses origines
familial également et je pense que là où
l'attendent vraiment les Français
maintenant c'est peut-être qu'elle dise
qu'elle a vraiment envie de ce poste et
c'est peut-être ce qui a manqué dans
cette dans ce grand
c'est de sentirah l'envie d'être
présidente de la République l'envie de
continuer elle a parlé de du service de
l'État de service servir la population
française il manque encore peut-être un
peu dans les prochains jours j'imagine
dans les prochaines semaines à affiner
cette
envie de devenir président de la
République alors peut-être qu'elle aura
l'occasion de le faire vendredi prochain
puisque il y a un prochain meeting au
côté d'ériicti dans les Alpes Maritimes
sera sur lequel on reviendra merci en
tous les cas Laur Salvin d'avoir
commenté avec nous d'avoir passé cet
après-midi plaisir partager avec les
internautes du Figaro ce meeting ce
premier grand meeting de de Valérie
PCR qui a réuni on vous le disait
quasiment 8000 personnes ici au Zénit
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi merci
beaucoup d'avoir commenter d'avoir réagi
d'avoir posé vos questions merci
beaucoup à Alban B de les avoir relayé
et d'avoir même supplé aux défaillances
parfois de la technique ça arrive merci
beaucoup de votre indulgence en tous les
cas dans ces moments qui sont toujours
un petit peu délicats merci à Daphné
Caravaca qui était de l'autre côté de la
caméra à Beni à en régie et à Sylvain
châtelin qui était à la
coordination vous restez avec nous on va
également analyser ce discours d'un
point de vue rhtorique et puis on se
retrouve demain pour les nouveaux
programmes de Figaro live merci d'avoir
été avec nous d'autres infos d'autres
vidéos c'est sur Le
Figaro